mes chers collègues nous allons
reprendre nos travaux avec ce matin une
table ronde consacrée au 20e
anniversaire de la Convention pour la
sauvegarde du patrimoine culturel
immatériel de
l'Unesco les édifices historiques et les
objets mobiliers ne sont pas les seuls
éléments de notre
patrimoine à la préservation desquels
notre commission est évidemment attaché
de longues dates les questions liées à
la sauvegarde du patrimoine culturel
immatériel relève aussi du champ de
compétenence en mai 2021 nos collègues
Marie-Pierre Monier et Catherine Duma
avaient réalisé au nom de notre
commission un rapport sur la mise en
œuvre de la Convention de l'UNESCO de
2003 pour la sauvegarde du PCI du
patrimoine culturel matatériel nous nous
étions alors engagés à assurer le suivi
de leurs travaux cette année qui
coïncide avec les 20 ans de la signature
de la convention la matinée du mercredi
étant réservée au aux travaux de nos
commissions ce n'est pas le jour de la
date universaire la signature de la
convention qui que se tient notre table
ronde mais le lendemain de celle-ci
j'espère que le choix de cette date au
plus proche de l'événement manifestera
une nouvelle fois tout l'intérêt que
notre Commission accorde à ce patrimoine
immatériel pour nous éclairer sur les
enjeux internationaux nationaux et
locaux associés à ce patrimoine et nous
faire part des PRS accompli depuis 2 ans
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir parmi
nous ce matin madame Fumiko oinata chef
de l'unité de mise en service de mise en
œuvre de la convention de 2003
l'UNESCO Monsieur Pierre SANET président
de
l'association PCI directeur de la
Mission française du patrimoine et des
cultures alimentaires à l'origine de
l'inscription en 2010 du repas
gastronomique des Français sur la liste
de l'UNESCO madame liliie martinet et
Monsieur Thomas mard qui va vous
rejoindre je pense chargé de mission
ethnologie et patrimoine imitériel à la
délégation et à l'inspection à la
recherche et l'innovation du ministère
de la Culture monsieur Cédric torisson
directeur de la Maison des Cultures du
mondre centre français du patrimoine
culturel im matatériel qui est
l'organisme qui a été désigné compétent
pour la sauvegarde du PCI sur le
territoire national et enfin Monsieur
Jean-Pierre l leu ancien sénateur ancien
membre éminent de notre commission
ancien maire de grâce et c'est à ce
titre euh enfin en tout cas de son
action à grâce puisqu'il a beaucoup vré
pour l'inscription des savoir-faire liés
au parfum de grâce obtenu en 2018 c'est
à ce titre bien sûr qu'il est euh euh
parmi nous ce matin et on a toujours
beaucoup de plaisir à à revoir et à
retrouver ici euh Jean-Pierre mesdames
et messieurs nous vous remercions
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation et
avant de vous laisser vous exprimer je
cède la parole à Marie-Pierre Monier
afin qu'elle revienne succintement sur
les principales recommandations du
rapport merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues et bonjour à toutes et
tous je vous remercie vraiment
sincèrement monsieur le Président
d'avoir pris l'initiative d'organiser
cette tableronde afin que notre
Commission puisse participer aux
célébrations de cette année marquante
pour la sauvegarde du patrimoine
culturel immatériel c'était un vœu qui
nous était très cher à Catherine et à
moi d'ailleurs vous nous avez toujours
accompagné auprès du ministère dans la
démarche que nous avons pu avoir
donc nous avons conduit elle et moi des
travaux en sur ce sujet en 2021 et je
vous prie d'excuser Catherine Duma qui
na pas pu être présente ce matin même si
la convention parle de patrimoine
culturel et matériel Catherine et
moi-même préférions la notion de
patrimoine vivant qui nous semble
beaucoup plus parlante en effet
ce qui caractérise le mieux tous les
savoirs savoir-faire traditions et
pratiques qui composent cette forme de
patrimoine et la distingue du patrimoine
matériel c'est ce caractère à la fois
vivant et dynamique il en résulte trois
conséquences d'abord sa sauvegarde est
un enjeu public majeur pour nos
territoires parce que peut-être plus
encore que le patrimoine matériel il est
un marqueur d'identité et un facteur de
cohésion et de lien social ensuite c'est
une forme de patrimoine extrêmement
vulnérable parce que les éléments
risquent à tout moment de disparaître
s'ils cessent d'être pratiqués et enfin
la sauvegarde du PCU PCI ne passe pas
par sa conservation comme le patrimoine
matériel mais par sa transmission d'où
l'importance de la sensibilisation de la
formation l'une des des difficultés
c'est que le PCI souffre en comparaison
du patrimoine matériel d'un fort déficit
de visibilité c'est une forme de
patrimoine qui reste encore très
largement méconnu et promu ce qui nuit à
sa sauvegarde on ne peut donc que se
féliciter que des outils comme la liste
représentative du patrimoine culturel
immatériel de l'humanité où l'inventaire
du PCI en France a été mise en place
dans les années afin de contribuer à sa
meilleure
reconnaissance reste maintenant à
parvenir à se les approprier
correctement l'inscription sur la liste
de l'UNESCO est évidemment perçue comme
un gral mais nous sommes convaincus que
l'inventaire national peut jouer un rôle
décisif qui justifie qu'il soit
davantage valorisé nous pensons aussi
que les collectivités territoriales ont
un rôle considérable à jouer pour
accompagner les détenteurs d'éléments de
PCI dans leur ambition de sauve-garde
tant celle-ci constitue un enjeu public
majeur pour les
territoires j'espère que Jean-Pierre
Leleu que je salue notre ancien collègue
pourra en sa qualité d'élu local nous
faire part du véritable projet de
territoire qu' a sans doute constitué
l'inscription des savoir-faire liés au
parfum de grâce sur la liste
représentative de l'UNESCO avec
Catherine Duma nous avions formulé 25
propositions
dans le but de permettre d'accroître la
visibilité du PCI de mieux y
sensibiliser de renforcer les moyens
dédiés à sa sauvegarde d'améliorer
l'attractivité de l'Inventaire national
et de muscler l'action de l'UNESCO en
matière de
PCI je me réjouis de constater plusieurs
que plusieurs d'entre elles sont d'ors
et déjà ont déjà d'ors et déjà
excusez-moi été mis en œuvre et j'espère
que chacun de nos interlocuteurs pourra
évoquer à la fois les progrès accomplis
au cours des deux dernières anné et les
chantiers qui s'annoncent pour les
années à venir je vous
remercie merci alors donc ce matin on va
parler de patrimoine vivant pour reenir
une des propositions je vais vous donner
5 minutes chacun pour un propos
préalable et puis après bien sûr comme
nous avons l'habitude de le faire dans
cette commission nous échangerons à
travers des des questions j'imagine
nombreuses de la part de mes collègues
je je tiens à m'excuser de la chaleur il
fait un peu chaud dans cette pièce
profitez-en parce qu'on a mis la clim la
clime et et dans quelques instants il va
faire très froid vous verrez c'est une
spécificité de cette salle
euh sans plus tarder je donne la parole
à Madame oinata un propos
préalable bonjour monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénateur
sénateurs donc mon nom est FEM corinata
je fais partie du Secrétariat de la
Convention de 200 to pour la sauvegarde
de patrimoine culturel et matériel je
dirige une unité chargée des relations
intergouvernemental et des mécanismes de
coopération internationale au titre de
cette convention permettez-moi de
remercier les organisateurs de cette
table ronde d'avoir invité l'UNESCO
c'est un plaisir de participer à ce
forum au côté des principaux acteurs de
la convention de 2003 en France donc
donc cette réunion est organisée à la
suite de rapport adopté par la
commission de la culture du Sénat en
2021 et au nom de l'UNESCO je voudrais
saluer l'attention portée par le Sénat
pour cet instrument juridique
international de l'UNESCO dans le
domaine de la
culture la famille de patrimin vivant de
la convention de 2003 célèbre donc cette
année le 20e anniversa de la convention
adoptée il y a 20 ans quasiment jour
pour jour le 17 7 octobre à cette
occasion le secrétariat secrétariat de
l'UNESCO a mis en ligne un site web pour
connaître les activités entreprises par
les étatptis les institutions
culturelles les ONG les communautés du
monde entier pour célébrer cet
anniversaire
ensemble cette initiative s'est avérée
être une réussite avec plus de centaine
d'activités déjà présenté sur notre site
et bien entendu plusieurs événements
organisés en France sont également
inclus et cela rejoint d'ailleurs la
recommandation du rapport de la
commission culture qui a préconisé de
faire de l'année 2023 l'année du
patrimoine vivant en France je cite
recommandation
2 alors donc qu'est-ce qu'on célèbre au
juste queles sont les réalisations
majeures de la convention je vis ré
prendre ici quelques minutes si vous me
permz monsieur le Président pour
esquisser les principaux impacts que la
convention de 2003 a pe avoir au cours
des 20 dernières années tout en évoquant
aussi les perspectives
futures tout d'abord la convention de
2003 peut-être à considéré considéré
comme un succès en raison de sa portée
universelle le rythme de ratification a
été très rapide et nous comptons
désormais
181 état partis couvrant toutes les
régions du monde et il semble que
plusieurs autres pays vont bientôt
rejoindre notre famille le secrétariat
est d'ailleurs toujours intéressé par
les activités entreprises par des
institutions en France comme la Maison
des Cultures du Monde pour comprendre et
soutenir les efforts de sauvegarde mené
dans les pays qui n'ont pas encore
ratifié la Convention de de
2002 une autre réussite claire et
majeure de la convention est
l'élargissement de la notion même de
patrimoine pour y inclure l'importance
de la sauvegarde du
PCI aujourd'hui cela peut sembler aller
de soi même on parle de patrimoin vivant
mais rappelons-nous qu'il y a 20 ans
seul une poignée de pays reconnaissait
le concept de P moin
vivant la Convention a donc fermement
établi la sauvegarde du patrimoine
culturel immatériel au niveau
international et est devenu une
référence clé pour ces état parties dans
la conception des politiques publiques
et des lois nécessaires à cette
sauvegarde selon des informations
recueilli en 2021 grâce au mécanisme de
rapport périodique de de notre
convention
98 % des pays d'Europe ont déclaré avoir
des politiques ou des mesures juridiques
ou administratives dans le secteur
culturel qui intégre la sauvegarde du
patrimoine
vivant près de 80 % des pays européens
ont également déclaré disposer des
politiques de mux juridique ou
administrative dans le secteur de
l'éducation qui reconnaissent le patri
moins culturel immatériel et
l'importance de sa transmission il
s'agit là d'une immense réussite de la
convention maintenant je voulais parler
de
l'inscription le secrétairia estime que
la sensibilisation au patrimoine vivant
au niveau
international a été considérablement
accru au cours des 20 dernières années
notamment grâce à l'inscription
d'éléments sur les listes de la
Convention il y a 76 éléments inscrits
sur la liste de saucadre duurent
567 éléments insclrit sur la liste
représentative 33 éléments insclrit sur
le régistr à des bonnes pratiques de
sauvegarde il y a en tout
676 éléments reconnus par le système de
liste de la convention de 2003 mais il y
a surtout 676 histo à raconter de
communauté pratiquant chacun de ces
éléments à titre personnel j'ai eu la
chance de visiter la ville de grâ il y a
quelques années j'attends moi aussi avec
l'impatience d'entendre le sénateur
loulou parler de l'expérience des
communautés suite à l'inscription des
savoirs fait alliés au parfum des pays
de grâce ont-ils le sentiment que la
reconnaissance de l'UNESCO les a aidé à
mieux transmettre à leur connaissance
leurs connaissance ou ont-ils subi des
effets indésirables de l'inscription tel
qu'une
commercialisation excessive ou une
appropriation
illicite le système d'inscription de la
Convention a également réussi à mettre
en valeur incroyable diversité et la
richerche du patrimoine vivant les liste
inclue désormais des aliments des sports
et des J traditionnel des connaissances
médicinales locales des espaces
culturels entiers ainsi de suite et la
France est aussi un champion avec 26
éléments inscrits ces éléments nous
émveillent quant à la créativité humaine
et en même temps la liste de la
convention remet en question notre
conception de patrimoine vivant je
serais intéressé de connaître l'avis
d'un expert t que M passanet président
de l'association France PCI sur ce point
une tendance importante à souligner est
le nombre à croissance de candidatures
des
multinational ce qui signifie que plus
de deux états partis se réunissent pour
proposer conjointement l'inscription
d'un élément de patrimoin vivant il
s'agit d'un mécanisme très important
pour la coopération
internationale monsieur le Président il
existe il existe actuellement 74
éléments mul tionaux correspondant à 101
pays la France compte le plus grand
nombre d'éléments multinationaux sur les
listes avec 11 inscriptions sur 26
éléments son multinationaux donc suivi
par les pays comme les Émirats arabes
unis l'Iran la Turquie Oman l'Azerbaïjan
et le Kazakhstan et C il sera il serait
très intéressant d' d'entendre les
expériences des repr présentant du
ministre de la Culture ici présent de
leur expérience pour préparer tel
candidature et la mise en œuvre de
mesures de sauvegarde de ces
éléments bien qu'il y ait tant d'autres
réalisation et dialog que je voudrais
mentionner permettez-moi de dire
quelques mots juste sur notre approche
au Mani d'assistance internationale et
de renforcement des capacités qui a
connu un succès considérable
grâce au fonds de la convention de 2003
plus de 10 millions de dollars d'aide
ont été accordés accordé pour financer
une centaine de projets dans 60 pays
depuis
2008 en matière de renforcement des
capacité le Secrétariat de la Convention
a mené des activités dans plus de 138
pays à travers le réseau de 200
facilitateurs la France a été un acteur
important à cet égard notamment en terme
d'expertise que nous sollicitons ou à
travers le soutien qu'il apporte sous
forme de contribution financière
l'UNESCO reconnaît et remercie le
soutien de la France pour la mise en
œuvre de la
convention je je commence à terminer mon
intervention donc l'année actuelle de
20e anniversaire offre l'occasion de
réfléchir aux orientations futures que
le que la convention de 2003 pour
répondre à
l'avenir point culminant de
l'anniversaire une réunion globale a
eulu en juillet cette année à sol en
République de Corée pour discuter de la
vision de la Convention et plus concr
concrètement de la manière dont le
patrimoine vivant pourrait améliorer les
conditions de vie respectant les
connaissances locales de la manière dont
le patrimoine vivant pourrait créer une
relation plus harmonieuse avec la nature
et la planète comment le patrimoin
vivant pourrait renforcer une éducation
transformatrice et de qualité et de
comment le patrimoine vivant pourrait
promouvoir la diversité et le dialogue
dans l'environnement numérique dans
toutes les régions de monde les
résultats de la Réunion sont résumés
dans un document intitulé vision de sol
alors que l'UNESCO travaillera sur tous
les domaines mises en évidence par cette
vision du souhaite souligner certains
des initiatives concrètes que le
Secrétariat a déjà commencé à
entreprendre premier les communautés
sont en cur de la Convention il est donc
essentiel de mettre au premier plan leur
voix principe fondamental de la
convention l'UNESCO continuura de
renforcer la participation de la société
civile notamment des jeunes et des
peuples autochtones nous réfléchissons
actuellement à la meilleure manière de
enrichir le partage de bon expérien en
matière de sauvegarde à travers les
mécanismes de la convention notamment
via une plateforme
enlne le Secrétariat de la Convention a
lancé aussi deuxièmement trois
initiatives thématiques pour explorer
les moyens de répondre aux problèmes
mondiaux urgents il concerne les
dimensions économiques de la sauvegarde
de PCI le ptholement culturel immatériel
et le changement climatique et le
sauvegarde du PCI dans des contextes
urbains dans un premier temps notre
objectif est d'élaborer des documents
d'orientation pour mieux comprendre les
principales questions
impliquées l'UNESCO continue aussi de
rechercher des synergies entre les six
conventions culturelles de
l'organisation pour notre convention de
2003 davantage de lien devrai être
établi par exemple avec la convention de
patrimon mondial de
72 comment pourrions-nous promouvoir des
politiques intégrées pour la protection
et la sauvegarde de patriument culturel
matériel et immatériel qu le mécanisme
de coordination pourrionss-nous imaginer
pour traiter et évaluer les candidatures
connectes
soumise par les États parties aux deux
conventions comment pourrionss-nous
accroître à la participation des
communautés autochtones locales et
autres à la protection et à la
sauvegarde conjointe des lieux et des
pratiques associées du patrimoine vivant
les questions ne manquent pas je
constate que votre rapport avait déjà
évoqué des initiatives ou des
recommandations qui sont directement
transposables à notre propre
réflexion on minant j'aimerais encore
une fois souligner l'importance de
travailler tous ensemble pour
ouvrir au développement futur de la
convention de
2003 qui dépend largement de
l'investissement des étatptis des
institutions culturelles ainsi que des
ONG et même des associations plus
locales puisque ce sont elles qui sont
les plus proches des communautés qui
elles-même sont au cœur du processus de
la mise en de la combonion et je vous
remercie beaucoup pour votre attention
merci merci madame monsieur
Sané mon
Président Monsieur le Président Mesdames
les sénatrices monsieur monsieur les
sénateurs chè madame merci beaucoup pour
cette
euh introduction préliminaire qui cadre
bien le l'importance de ce que cet outil
de la Convention de 2003 avec laquelle
on doit l'avouer nous autres Français ça
avait été souligné dans le rapport de
Madame dum et Madame Monier sommes bien
peu familiers quoi que maintenant je
pense que c'est rentré dans les dans les
Meur dans les mentalités vous l'avez dit
c'est aussi au cœur des des territoires
et à cet égard je vais vous présenter
l'association France France PCI mais
avant de avant d'oublier même si je
l'avais tout de même noté dans le cadre
des célébrations du 20e anniversaire de
la Convention pour la sauvegarde du
patrimoine culturel et immatériel nous
organisons l'association France PCI à de
pas d'ici la Société de Géographie
boulevard boulevard Saint-Germain le 24
novembre un colloque qui a pour thème
justement le patrimoine vivant au cœur
de nos territoires je pense c'est un
point qui sera développé par sénateur
maire honoraire Jean-Pierre Leleu
également mais c'est pour dire combien
cette créativité humaine s'exprime et
s'illustre sur ensemble de no territoire
évidemment métropolitain et ultramarin
c'est aussi ça une des spécificités de
des inscription euh françaises alors ces
inscriptions des des éléments français
euh moi j'aiis coutume de dire que
parfois ça ressemble un peu à une liste
à la prévre parce qu'elle est
extrêmement riche extrêmement
enthousiasmante on découvre des tas de
de de pratique d'État d'expression des
histoires à raconter pour reprendre vos
vos vos propos madame et je et c'est bon
ce sont ces histoires que nous essayons
de de réunir au sein de l'association
France France PCI pour leur donner un
peu de chair euh et pour effectivement
le le partager au plus grand nombre et
faire en sorte que nous soyons un peu
plus familier là aussi parf on peut le
le rappeler au fond on est d'utres
français un peu comme comme Monsieur
Jourdin dans le B gentilhomme finalement
on fait du PCI sans même le savoir ou on
fait en fait du Patrimoine Vivant euh
sans même le savoir ceci dit je pense
qu'effectivement euh l'un l'un des
points qui a été soulevé et qui sera
probblement à travailler par votre
commission et et par nous-mêmes et ces
liens entre alors la convention de 72
bien entendu et celle de et celle de
2003 mais au-delà de ça enfin à travers
cela les les les liens euh frappants euh
qui existent entre le patrimoine mondial
euh non pas ces vieilles pierres mais le
patrimoine mondial construit et euh et
les pratiques euh les savoir-fa les
connaissances et je crois qu'on l'a vu
de façon
très c'était très très enrichissant et
instructif ça est toujours d'ailleurs je
crois sur le chantier de Notre-Dame où
l'ensemble où ce patrimoine mondial
connu reconnu apprécié de de tous est
également a pu être ce sentier de de
restauration se se poursuit grâce à
l'ensemble de ces de ces métiers au fond
c'est un peu cela le le patrimoine
culturel et matériel ce patrimoine
vivant euh donc la l'association France
PCI a été créé en partie l'initiative du
pouvoir public il faut reconnaître qu'
il faut remercier le les les services du
ministère de la Culture qui sont dit il
faut réunir dès
2012 l'ensemble des représentants des
éléments français inscrits sur la liste
du patrimoine culturel immatériel sur
les listes sur l'une des listes parce
que vous l'avez dit il y a les les
listes de
sauvegarde la liste représentative les
bonnes pratiques et et au fond sur
l'ensemble de ces possibilités la France
est emparée très tôt de de cet outil euh
de cet outil merveilleux et je le sais
d'autant plus vous l'avez souligné
puisque j'ai pu faire partie de cette
équipe qui euh dès 2010 a permis la
reconnaissance du repa gonomique des
Français euh donc au au au au lendemain
de la mise en œuvre du de la convention
notre notre association réunit
aujourd'hui la quasi-ttalité euh des euh
des membres de cette liste dite à la
prèverre donc les les les 25 enfin les
membres les 25 éléments euh inscrits euh
sont euh quelques setions près sur
lesquelles nous nous travaillons membres
de l'association France
PCI la première réunion avait lieu en
2012 et elle existe donc depuis depuis
2013 avec la volonté de de valoriser nos
nos inscriptions valoriser la diversité
de prendre part aux réflexions
politiques du patrimoine culturel
immatériel en France et de faire en
sorte aussi d'avoir un dialogue avec les
les services du Secrétariat à la
Convention au sein de au sein de
l'UNESCO formellement nous avons
été nous existons depuis depuis
2013 et pour ma part je
suis président depuis la
la l'assemblée générale de pzenas en en
2017 et ce que nous avons essayé de de
faire avec des des des des
moyens limités mais soutenu par le par
le ministère de la Culture de faire en
sorte que chaque assemblée générale soit
nomade puisse aller que nous soyons pas
toujours euh soit à Paris soit dans un
même endroit donc nous étions à auenas
euh pardon à pesonas à Alençon à auusson
et nous avons pu présenter lors de
l'assemblée générale à grass en
2021 le rapport et Catherine Duma nous
avait fait la l'amitié de de venir le
présenter sur place alors c'est c'est
euh ces assemblées générales sont bon
formellement le le rôle d'e d'une
association c'est également
l'opportunité
de partager des expertises de partager
des des expériences de visiter les lieux
qui euh qui donc à la Cité
Internationale de de d'au buuson par
exemple qui est qume un lieu de
transmission extrêmement important de
ces savoir-fa de visiter l'ensemble de
celles et ceux qui permettent au parfum
de grâce d'avoir cette cette réputation
cette renommée lorsque nous étions la
grâce de mesurer la fragilité aussi de
pratique lorsqu'on était à la à alançon
il y a il reste peu de de dentelière
sachons-le et pourtant c'est des c'est
des savoirs et et des connaissances
extrêmement extrêmement importante donc
les les missions de la de notre notre
structure notre association c'est
évidemment contribuer à une meilleure
connaissance je l'ai dit un peu en
préambule de l'esprit de la de la
convention euh de faciliter les échanges
et les partages d'information de
connaissance et d'expérience euh
d'encourager la collaboration à
l'échelle nationale et et internationale
de faire des propositions de réflexion
d'être une sorte d'outil si je puis dire
au service des des différentes
politiques publiques et notamment
principalement auprès du du ministère de
la de la culture d'intervenir sur les
sujets de du du patrimoine et d'insister
à ce que le patrimoine immatériel le
patrimoine vivant vous avez raison que
c'est le terme bien plus approprié et
plus parlant euh puisse être présent en
toutes les grandes célébration nationale
et à cet égard c'est vrai que les
Journées européennes du patrimoine
pourrai devrai avoir à chaque fois une
représentation du du patrimoine du
patrimoine vivant nous avons été donc
auditionné aussi lors de la lors de la
préparation du du rapport qui a été qui
a été
cité nous nous avons créé et à la
disposition de l'ensemble des acteurs
culturel ou d' tuers associatifs en
France une exposition qui méritera
d'être en partie repensé maintenant des
des 25 éléments donc une exposition
itinérante des 25 éléments inscrits sur
l'une des listes du patrimoine culturel
im matatériel cette cette exposition a
itinéré elle est elle est présente dans
dans différents différents lieux et elle
sera mais je ne veux
pas parler avant juste un tout petit peu
avant le sénateur m Jean-Pierre Lleu
elle sera présente à grâce à l'occasion
d'un anniversaire qui va être fêté mais
Don je pense que Jean-Pierre lu nous
dira un mot euh à grassce donc c'est un
outil à la disposition de tous et on
s'est rendu compte que elle avait un
impact en matière de pédagogie et
d'accompagnement euh en direction des
notamment des des jeunes publics euh et
des scolaires donc cette exposition
était voilà est un des outils qui
participe d'une meilleure connaissance
et d'e meilleure appréhension de ce
patrimoine vivant euh euh français on a
également publié euh un ouvrage aux
édition Dakota euh où justement le lien
est fait entre le patrimoine mondial et
euh le patrimoine
immatériel et enfin nous travaillons et
c'est un sujet sur lequel peut-être par
la suite j'aimerais dire un mot
à une collection d'ouvrages de bande
dessinée sur l'ensemble de ces éléments
du patrimoine cultur et matatériel
sachant que la bande dessinée peut-être
l'un des outils médiatiques les plus
populaires et on espère avoir comme ça
notre contribution également à toutes
ces à toutes ces réflexions voilà je
vous remercie de votre attention et et
reste évidemment à disposition pour la
la suite des débats merci je donner la
parole maintenant au représentants du
ministère de la Culture peut-être si
vous pouvez nous faire un point sur les
les projets enfin les les éléments déjà
inscrits les 25 si j'ai bien retenu le
le le chiffre et et ceux qui sont en en
voie d'inscription ou en candidature en
tout cas qu' qu' prenne un petit peu
aussi la diversité pour chacun de nos
collègues la diversité de de ce que
représente le le patrimoine vivant
notamment dans nos territoires puisque
évidemment chacun ici représente un
territoire alors bonjour à tous monsieur
le Président euh mesdames les sénatrices
et messieurs les sénateurs on est
vraiment ravi euh thomas et moi d'être
présent aujourd'hui et euh et je prends
cette opportunité pour vous remercier
pour le rapport parce que le rapport
pour nous c'est un peu une feuille de
route on a des recommandations et on a
des objectifs à atteindre donc c'est
vraiment pour nous c'est un document de
de référence dans euh la mise en œuvre
de la Convention et dans les projets
futurs de mise en œuvre donc ça c'est
vraiment très utile et
euh je pense que c'est important quand
même de rappeler euh au sein du
ministère de la Culture voilà on est
deux chargé de mission pour le
patrimoine culturel matérial donc ici
vous avez les deux personnes euh qui
s'occupent de la mise en œuvre de la
Convention et
euh sur ce point on avec Thomas on quand
on préparait cette intervention
aujourd'hui on on a essayé de faire le
point sur toutes les recommandations et
sur ce qui a été mis en œuvre et ce qui
reste encore à être mis en œuvre donc si
vous en êtes d'accord on peut peut-être
très rapidement balayer les les
recommandations et et on va le faire à
devoir bon très
bien du couper votre micro merci pour
les questions qui sont liées euh à la
visibilité du patrimoine culturel et
matériel donc maintenant on a un
département au au sein de la Dirie qui
qui contient le nom patrimoine culturel
matériel donc c'est le département de la
recherche de la valorisation et du
patrimoine culturel matériel donc le le
PCI est visible dans l'organigramme du
ministère de la
Culture pour l'année
2023 donc on a eu énormément d'activités
en lien avec les Journées européennes du
patrimoine il y a le colloc qui est
organisé par France PCI on a également
organisé une réunion de mise en réseau
des ONG àé
donc un point très important parce que
les ONG accrédités jouent un rôle
important dans la mise en œuvre de la
Convention on a également créé un agenda
participatif sur lequel les communautés
pouvaient inscrire des événements il y a
également un événement festif qui aura
lieu le 8 novembre auutour du fesnos qui
sera une soirée de célébration en
immersion dans le patrimoine culturel
matérial je pas détailler tout tous les
événements pour garder le temps pour les
journées du patrimoine culturel matériel
on a chaque année le Centre français du
patrimoine culturel matériel qui
organise une journée du patrimoine
culturel matérial l'INALCO a a initié
cette année une journée du patrimoine
culturel Matal qui devrait être répétée
les années prochaines et on a aussi un
des journées du patrimoine culturel
Matal antiguyane donc aussi pour
l'outrem et euh pour les questions de
panneau d'information alors vraiment on
se voit que les communautés se sont et
ont investi l'emblème et on a des
exemples d'emblème que Thomas et moi
pouvons voir quand nous sommes en
mission donc par exemple on l'a vu au
salon de l'agriculture en lien avec la
transumance ou Thomas l'a vu en lien
avec un jeu de boule de fort donc on
voit que l'emblème est en train de
d'être connu et donc voilà et pour je je
vais laisser la parole à Thomas pour
qu'il puisse avoir un peu de temps
oui monsieur le Président madamees les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs chers
chers collègues donc pour continuer un
peu la le bilan finalement sur les
recommandations de de de de ce rapport
de de 2021
euh et bien il y avait un point et une
partie visant à mieux sensibiliser au
PCI euh on peut effectivement le le
rapport le souligne cette cet instrument
ça a été dit aussi par par Pierre sanner
euh comment à être connu mais il est
encore on pourrait dire sousutilisé et
peut-être dans dans certains cas
peut-être mal utilisé mal encore mal
compris donc il est important encore et
nous on le fait chaque jour depuis nos
nos fonctions de chargé de mission en
administration centrale nos collègues
aussi dans les Dracs à mieux faire
comprendre ce qui est le
PCI ce qu'il n'est pas
aussifà par exemple ça n'est pas un
label que l'on viendrait poser un label
UNESCO ou inventaire national sur une
pratique mais c'est un outil de
démocratie culturelle qui s'adresse
voilà qui a des effets
intergénérationnels ça a été souligné
tout ce qu' a rappelé la chef de l'unité
du patrimoine vivant à l'Unesco qui vise
à décloisonner les politiques
culturelles et pas seulement puisque on
est très souvent en interministériel sur
les questions du PCI et on le voit très
bien fonctionner aux échelles donc
territoriales même depuis depuis Paris
donc mieux sensibilisé au PCI il y avait
comme une des mesures qui nous étaient
proposées d'éveiller les jeunes au
patrimoine culturel et matériel c'est
aussi un un axe prioritaire de de de
l'UNESCO donc nous avons organisé cette
année avec ma collègue liliie Martinet
des rencontres professionnelles sur
l'éducation artistique et culturelle
croisé avec le domaine du patrimoine
culturel immatériel on s'est rendu
compte que avec nos collègues du
ministère de la culture mais aussi du
ministère de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation de l'éducation nationale
on avait tout à faire ensemble pour
développer ce cette éducation artistique
et culturelle dans le domaine très
diverse du Patrimoine Vivant eu il était
question aussi de sensibiliser les élus
locaux aux enjeux liés à la sauvegarde
du PCI notamment par des formations et
là on peut rappeler qu'il existe des
quatre formations permanentes ouvertes à
tous donc y compris aux élus et au
agents techniques des collectivités
territoriales qui sont dispensés par des
etthnopôes c'est un label euh cette fois
un vrai label que l'on que l'on
administre aussi au Département de la
recherche de la valorisation et du PCI
euh qui sont répartis sur le territoire
national
euh c'était
également faire le point sur euh la
formation toujours et vous vous partagez
avec vous l'information que l'on
travaill avec l'Institut national du
patrimoine aussi en direction donc des
des conservateurs stagiaires des
professionnels du patrimoine et on a mis
en œuvre aussi cette année une formation
qui va se qui va devenir annuelle pour
les agents du ministère de la culture ou
là aussi he le le patrimoine culturel
immatériel est au sens de la Convention
UNESCO et encore parfois pas bien pas
bien saisi euh dans ce son son ces
domaines et dans les principes de sa
mise en œuvre
euh donner plus de moyens à la
sauvegarde du PCI et il était question
il est toujours d'ailleurs de nommer des
référents dans les serv déconcentrés les
les Dracs les DACs alors on a avancé
mais il y a encore quelques quelques
Dracs où la désignation d'un conseiller
référent est en cours et ça c'est
important évidemment parce que ça a été
souligné en fait il y a aussi peu de
moyens qui sont mis sur cette politique
publique pour l'instant en tout cas par
rapport aux demandes qui surgissent et
qui sont de plus importante ça on peut
aussi le constater de la part de la
société civile mais aussi des élus et
euh
donc c'est en cours mais on va organiser
une première réunion de tous ces
conseillers des DRAC l'année prochaine
et ensuite ça sera
récurrent voilà c'est manque peut-être
un peu de temps monsieur le Président
pour faire le point sur toutes les
mesures qui étit en nombre et au nombre
de 21 mais mais on avance du mieux qu'on
peut avec les moyens qu'on a pour
l'instant à notre disposition voilà on y
reviendra sûrement à travers les
questions en tout cas merci d'avoir
souligné la la qualité du travail fait
par Marie-Pierre Monier et Catherine
Duma et et de constater que c'est la
feuille de route d'un service du
ministère c'est pour nous une un élément
intéressant dans notre dans nos travail
pour pour nos travaux pour l'avenir
pardon je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur
torisson avant que Jean-Pierre l leu ne
ne conclue les la première série
d'intervention monsieur le Président
Mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs tout d'abord merci de de votre
invitation sein de la Maison des
Cultures du monde alors je vais essayer
d'être bref ça risque d'être un je vais
essayie de pas déborder première chose
mais je voulais vous faire un petit
rappel historique déjà de ce qui est la
Maison des Cultures du Monde et pourquoi
elle a été désignée à partir de 2011
comme centre français du patrimoine
culturel immatériel alors la Maison des
Cultures du Monde a été créé en en
1982 avec le soutien du du ministère de
la culture et du réseau des Alliances
françaises donc l'Alliance française de
Paris à l'époque était la tête de pontte
du réseau des Alliances françaises au
niveau mondial et le président mitéran à
l'époque d'ailleurs en 82 avait cité
cette Maison des Cultures du Monde cette
volonté de créer à Paris une Maison des
Cultures du Monde pour favoriser en
effet le dialogue interculturel le
dialogue entre les peuples donc on est
en 1982 en 1984 la Maison des Cultures
du Monde crée une première revue qui
s'appelle l'international de
l'imaginaire 30 euh publications environ
de l'International de l'imaginaire donc
quatre commenceront à traiter déjà du
patrimoine culturel immatériel avant la
ratification par la France en 2006 de la
convention UNESCO donc c'est déjà un
sujet en soi qui irrigait les réflexions
au sein de la Maison des Cultures du
Monde et cette revue à l'époque était
dirigée par Jean du Vigot qui est
anthropologue dramaturge et qui a été
par
ailleurs directeur d'un laboratoire de
sociologie de l'imaginaire à Paris 7 en
1985 la maison crée le label inédit
aujourd'hui c'est 136 références de
musique de tradition orale on va dire et
d'essens patrimonial du monde entier qui
couvre à peu près la totalité des
continents euh qui nous donne aussi une
on va dire un lien avec de la
coopération internationale avec
notamment aussi des ambassades qui
peuvent être présente à Paris et qui
nous sollicit de temps en temps pour
justement retrouver des dans le label
inédit des des des musiques qui ont été
enregistré à l'époque parfois eux-mêm
non'ont pas c'était le cas de Taiwan
l'année dernière notamment sur des
musique de taiïwan des communauté
aborigè boun en 94 donc il y a une
refondte de l'International de
l'imaginaire avec une publication euh
une édition avec Babel Acte Sud qui
s'arrêtera 10 ans plus tard
malheureusement mais des ouvrages qui
sont encore disponibles en ligne pour
certains d'entre eux euh en 95 il y a un
colloque de fondation de
l'ethnocénologie alors une discipline
aussi intéressante en terme de
patrimoine immatériel parce que elle est
à la fois interrange des des réflexions
autour de l'anthropologie culturelle
mais aussi des arts de la scène et la
question est comment peut-on accueillir
en France dans des dispositifs
artistiques culturels des théâtres qui
sont pensé par notre société notre
manière de percevoir les choses des
cultures qui viennent du monde entier et
qui eux ont une autre représentation
spatiale donc c'était tout à fait
intéressant en matière d'ethnocénologie
de s'interroger aussi sur l'autre de ce
point de vue-là en 97 la création du
festival de l'imaginaire qui est
lui-même donc un festival dédié aux
formes spectaculaires du monde entier
essentiellement de tradition avec des
des des formes spectaculaire qui relève
du Patrimoine Vivant donc l'entrée
Maison des Cultures du Monde vers le
patrimoine culturel immatériel c'est
fait faite au départ autour des ararts
de la scène et du spectacle en 2004 il y
a l'ouverture à Vitré donc en Bretagne
du centre de documentation sur les
spectacles du monde parce que toutes ces
archives collectées sur le terrain il
était très difficile de les stocker ici
à Paris donc un lieu a été ouvert en
Bretagne en 2011 c'est ce lieu-là qui
sera désigné comme le centre français du
patrimoine culturel immatériel après que
la France aura ratifié en effet la
convention en 2006 et désigné un
organisme donc compétent pour pour la
sauvegarde du PCI sur son territoire tel
que c'est mentionné à l'article 13 il me
semble de la Convention en 2013 la
création donc d'une revue en ligne qui
fait qui assure la continuité de
l'ancienne Revue internationale de
l'imaginaire qui s'appelle celle-ci les
Cahiers du cfpci et puis madame la
sénatrice vous l'avez bien évoqué ça
tombe bien parce que nous à partir de
2024 on va nommer ces cahiers du cfpci
les Cahiers du Patrimoine Vivant donc ça
sera la nouvelle revue en effet de la
Maison des Cultures du Monde qui
traitera entièrement euh de ce thème du
patrimoine culturel immatériel mais sous
ce prisme de patrimoine vivant en 2016
nous recevons le label donc etthnopole
du ministère de la Culture Thomas l'a
bien rappelé c'est le pôle national de
recherche et de ressources en ethnologie
pour des structures qui mènent à la fois
des réflexions dans ce domaine mais
aussi des actions artistiques et
culturelles et en 2017 donc toute
l'équipe de la Maison des Cultures du
Monde quitte Paris et
se s'installe donc à Vitré en Bretagne
dans le centre français du patrimoine
culturel immatériel raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui nous appelons Maison des
Cultures du Monde centre français du
patrimoine culturel immatériel la Maison
des cultures du monde d'un point de vue
opérationnel c'est 8 ETP 2 et demi à peu
près dédié à la question du PCI
h alors je vais vous présenter un petit
peu nos objectifs par que nous avons une
convention triénale avec le Ministère de
la Culture une partie sur les donc sur
tout le volet coopération aspect
interculturel international sous
l'entrée spectacle mais une autre partie
aussi qui concerne exclusivement le
patrimoine vivant
donc les missions qui sont les nôtres
dans le cadre de cette convention
triénale qui devrait être rediscutée
cette année pour de nouveau être
opérante à partir de 2024 jusqu'à 2027
nous avons la sensibilisation des
publics à la sauvegarde du patrimoine
culturel immatériel un appui à la
structuration de réseaux d'information
sur le patrimoine culturel im matériel
en France en lien avec les réseaux
étrangers internationaux et les éléments
français inscrits sur les listes de
l'UNESCO y compris les ONG accrédités
auprès de l'Unesco sur notre territoire
des chercheurs et des institutions en
France et en Europe l'enrichissement
d'une documentation et d'une base de
données contribuant à la connaissance et
à la promotion en France du patrimoine
culturel immatériel la contribution à la
production des connaissances sur le
patrimoine culturel immatériel et à la
réflexion sur la sauvegarde et les
politiques du patrimoine immatériel au
niveau local national et international
et enfin contribution à à l'échange à
l'expertise entre professionnels alors
différents moyens sont mis en œuvre pour
cela nous avons des actions de
valorisation de médiation du patrimoine
culturel immatériel avec des expositions
des ateliers des résidences des
activités pédag des rencontres des
formations que nous mettons aussi en
place en lien avec les partenaires
universitaires et
institutionnels mais aussi la
numérisation d'archives parce que nous
avons de nombreuses archives nous avons
dès la création de la Maison des
Cultures du Monde l'idée a été de
conserver donc de filmer de garder de
sauvegarder toutes ces archives là qui
sont
donc une sorte de témoignage ce qui est
important en matière de transmission
aussi du patrimoine vivant et puis nous
organisons chaque année un colloque
Inter national annuel des séminaires des
publications euh notamment dans cette
collection en ligne des Cahiers du
patrimoine culturel immatériel alors
pour aller un peu plus dans les dans le
volet opérationnel C année cette année
2023 qui n'est pas encore terminé ces
cinq interventions dans les universités
notamment en Renn 2 sur bonne nouvelle
Toulouse qui a monté d'ailleurs un
master d'expertise ethnologique en
patrimoine immatériel c'est Scien poex
avec un Master 2 en coopération
culturelle internationaleuniversité de
franchecté sur les arts du spectacle C
événements organisés donc la journée du
patrimoine immatériel Lili l'a rappelé
qui s'organise chaque année dans le
cadre du festival de l'imaginaire qui a
lieu ici à Paris cette année le thème
était danse en résistance à la Cité
internationale des
Arts la Journée européenne du patrimoine
qui une partie cette année dédiée au
patrimoine immatériel donc nous avons
aussi uvré pour ouvrir nos portes et
accueillir les gens dans nos locaux à
Vitré et leur faire une présentation
détaillée de ce qu'est le patrimoine
culturel immatériel un séminaire en anop
ie de la danse que nous organisons
prochainement et que nous organisons
chaque année des formations sur le
PCI avec des étudiants de l'université
Ren 2 et Bretagne Occidentale je vais
juste baler rapidement dans ces quatre
représentations dans des séminaires neuf
participations à des tables rondes
quatre projets de sensibilisation en
éducation artistique et culturelle ça
c'est très important dont deux que je
tiens à souligner ici et qui coche cette
partie territoire 1 dans un lycée
agricole il y a des choses très
intéressantes à développer en matière
DEAC dans les établissements agricoles
c'est le cas avec le lycée saint-exupéri
à vitrée donc nous commençons cette
année une opération EAC patrimoine
immatériel qui rejoindra d'ailleurs les
questions autour du patrimoine naturel
quelque part sur la sauvegarde aussi
c'est c'est très important et un autre à
Livri Gargan donc en sain saintis c'est
75 he DEAC avec le soutien du conseil
départemental de saint-sen ville qui
situé entre Sevran et ébondi voilà 75 he
dédié au patrimoine vivant en
particulier sur sur une entrée Polynésie
et sur les danses polynésiennes ce qui
faisait aussi un peu écho à l'accueil en
France de la Coupe du monde de rugby
euh je rappelle simplement pour le lycée
agricole nous aurons aussi un un travail
en commun avec l'ENP l'Institut national
du patrimoine qui viendra nous appuyer
d'ailleurs sur cette démarche assassé en
lycée agricole et je trouve là c'est
intéressant comme lien à pouvoir faire
entre voilà des zones rurales et en même
temps cet intérêt croissant du
patrimoine immatériel et enfin deux
publications je terminerai là-dessus une
sur les premières journées du patrimoine
culturel immatériel antiaiguillan dans
les Cahiers du cfpci numéro 9 et enfin
patrimoine culturel immatériel et musée
qui sortira normalement en fin d'année
voilà je vous remercie de votre
attention merci Jean-Pierre Leleu pour
nous faire part de l'expérience de grâce
et l'intérêt pour les territoires
justement de se réapproprier ce
patrimoine
vivant merci monsieur le
Président c'est avec plaisir et bonheur
que je trouve dans cette salle Médicis
que j'ai fréquenté jadis et je remercie
Laurent la fond le président de la
commission culture Marie-Pierre Monier
et toute l'équipe de la commission
culture de m'avoir demandé de d'apporter
ce
témoignage c'est effectivement un
témoignage d'une expérience parmi 1000
autres car vous l'avez su euh les
différents éléments qui figurent sur la
liste représentative sont extrêmement
variés et chacun euh à sa spécificité
donc c'est un cas d'école un cas
particulier que je suis venu euh
présenter j'ai lanché j'ai lancé cette
démarche en 2008 alors que j'étais
encore sénateur et maire de la ville de
grâce après mon et je l'ai poursuivi
après mon départ volontaire de la mairie
euh à la Présidence de l'Association que
j'ai intitulé patrimoine vivant du pays
de grâce cet élément euh des
savoir-faire liés au parfum en pays de
grâce a été inscrit sur la liste
représentative de l'UNESCO le 28 octobre
2018 novembre 2018 il y a 5 ans lors
d'un comité intergouvernemental qui
s'était réuni à l'île Maurice euh je
rappelle que la liste représentative en
France compte 21 membres 26 et il y a 26
membres inscrits en tout dans toutes les
catégories inutile de rappeler les deux
filières mais quand même c'est souvent
important contenu parfois d'expliquer
les choses entre la filière de la
convention de 2003 et celle de 1972 qui
concerne le patrimoine culturel qui lui
est plus visible parce que il est
souvent monumental et que le patrimoine
immatériel est beaucoup plus complexe à
faire connaître et à partager il
s'agissait dans mon esprit de rendre un
hommage par parulier à ce que j'ai
appelé les deux courbés c'est-à-dire ces
générations qui se sont succédées dans
cette activité depuis plus de 4 siècles
et qui se sont transmis de multiples
savoir-faire particuliers tant dans la
culture des plantes apparfum la domaine
agricole qui était particulièrement
menacé d'ailleurs par l'ambiance
actuelle les la connaissance et
l'expertise des matières premières en
parfumerie et les méthodes de
transformation en essence qui sont
également des éléments très complexes et
qui sont l'objet d'un savoir-faire
extrêmement précis et puis évidemment
l'art de composer le parfum qui est un
art qui n'est pas le monopole grassoi
qui existe également bien entendu à
Paris et dans le monde entier mais qui
s'intègre et le territoire du Pays de
grâce est est le seul lieu où les trois
éléments de cette filière de la fleire
au flacon ce sera se rassemble sur la
méthode de travail la méthode la
démarche est longue il faut le savoir
quand on l'aborde et il faut pas que ça
décourage
elle nécessite une implication et une
volonté politique très forte et continue
pour nous elle a duré 10 ans mais au
fond à postériori je ressens fortement
que elle ne doit pas faire peur cette
durée et au contraire elle est
extrêmement positive parce qu'elle
permet d'appréhender l'esprit qui anime
l'UNESCO et les qualités exigées pour
être reconnu et l'état d'esprit évolue
pendant toutes ces 10 années de travail
de contact de rencontrre pour arriver à
un dossier qui à la fin mérite
réellement d'être reconnu nous avons
opéré en trois phases une phase d'étude
et de faisabilité savoir si c'était pas
un peu trop ambitieux pour nous que de
se lancer dans cette démarche
rencontre avec les le ministère quelques
représentants de l'UNESCO l'ambassadeur
à l'époque Philippe Lalot puis une
démarche d'inscription à l'Inventaire
national car vous le savez vous ne
pouvez pas postuler à une reconnaissance
à l'Unesco sans être accompagné par
l'État membre et en l'occurrence pour
nous la France et cela atteint le dépôt
du dossier auprès de l'Unesco avec le
soutien et après le soutien
de la ministre à l'époque c'était audreé
azoulet soutien de la ministre de la
Culture 10 ans d'animation du territoire
en permanence pour
sensibiliser ce qu'on appelle en langage
unesquien les communautés c'est-à-dire
les personnes les hommes les femmes qui
sont quotidiennement sur le sujet avec
leur famille nous organisions deux
colloques par an en mai saison des roses
et en octobre pour célébrer l'
anniversaire de la Convention de
2003 de nombreuses rencontres avec la
Direction du Patrimoine au ministère de
la Culture et chacun des ministres de la
Culture avec en anecdote j'en ai connu h
en 12 ans voilà ça laisse ça veut dire
qu'il faut toujours reprendre à zéro les
contacts et et idem pour les
ambassadeurs à l'Unesco j'y reviendrai
plus tard qui mutent tous les 3 4 ans et
avec les quel il faut remonter à
l'assaut avec nos armes de conviction de
nombreux contacts avec la diplomatie
gonusienne bien sûr la
Constitution pour focaliser tout ça
après la perception d'une capacité à
obtenir notre but en 2013 de
l'association porteuse de de la démarche
rassemblant l'ensemble des praticiens ce
qu'on appelle les praticiens les
communautés de la filière un comité
scientifique des historiens des
anthropologues des sociologues de
manière à solidifier le fond de notre
démarche et sa raison
d'être avec évidemment le soutien de
tous les mèes des petites communes
autour du pays de grâce qui ont tout été
concernés par ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui notre story mais je dirait
tout simplement notre histoire les
difficultés que nous pouvons rencontrer
il est bon de les toucher du doigt
d'abord la porte d'entrée à l'Unesco est
étroite
elle est très étroite et je rappellerai
tout à l'heure que sur la l'inventaire
national il y a près de plus de 500
éléments inscrits que sur la liste
représentative il y en a 21 et que
désormais depuis quelques années
l'UNESCO n'accepte que ne soit présenté
à une candidature qu'une fois tous les 2
ans ça veut dire que quand je vous dis
souvent quand vous ratez le portillon
une année mais vous pouvez repartir dans
l'animation du territoire pendant 2 ans
encore si tantz que vous ayez ce qui a
été le cas la chance d'avoir été soutenu
par le Ministère de la Culture certes
des soutiens précieux dans les démarches
mais parfois des vents contraires euh
qui sont tout à fait légitimes des des
doutes exprimés autour de nous euh à la
fois dans la population qui parfois
considère que ce dont on parle c'est une
espèce de rêve que qui ne sera jamais
atteint ah oui où est-ce que vous en
êtes vous nous faites rêver mais ça
viendra jamais et cetera et parfois de
les obstacles institutionnels convaincre
le ministère de la Culture à l'époque
n'a pas été une chose forcément facile
et je le comprends parce que dans le
domaine qui était le nôtre le risque
d'une d'un flirt avec des des intérêts
économique et commerciaux pouvait
évidemment être entendu et il
m'appartenait de faire comprendre à nos
interlocuteur qui doutaiit que notre
objectif c'était pas du tout du
marketing du marketing commercial mais
c'était de d'expliquer ce qui se passait
au travers du flacon de parfum qu'on le
voit comme ça dans la dernière page du
Figaro avec du luxe que c'était de voir
ce qu'il y avait derrière avec les
plantes les cueillettes les greffages
les l'expertise des matières premières
et cetera donc après autre difficulté
les exigences de forme et de fond de
l'UNESCO le dossier laffiche
d'inventaire nécessite une rigueur ext
extrêmement potieuse dans laquelle il
faut soustraire tout élément d'affectif
il n'est pas question de de de mettre de
la l'affectivité mais uniquement de
l'objectivité dans l'ensemble des
dossiers afin que d'ailleurs l'affiche
d'inventaire soit bien comprise par les
multiples langues dont dispose l'UNESCO
il faut donc que le discours soit très
cadré dimension des textes nombre de
mots par question et cetera et cetera
une difficulté aussi mais ça a été cité
c'est que le patrimoine culture dans les
populations le patrimoine culturel
immatériel le patrimoine vivant est une
notion qui n'est pas encore
extrêmement pénétrante pénétrée et que
faut expliquer les choses il est
évidemment plus facile de communiquer
sur un bâtiment sur sur la basilique
d'ALB sur le château de Versailles sur
le mont sa-michel que sur un P
patrimoine immatériel qui nous manque
dont il nous manque un peu les quels
sont les effets que nous
avons constater de la démarche d'abord
j'en qualifierai trois les effets sur la
population les effets sur le territoire
et les effets sur l'économie
locale sur la population c'est une
merveille c'est le plus beau résultat
c'est le plus beau résultat une
formidable émulation de la population
faut savoir que toutes les familles dans
nos territoires ont touché ou travaill
de près ou de loin par leurs père leurs
fils leurs cousins leur oncle à ce
domaine toutes les familles sont
touchées et donc la démarche alors même
que chacun travaille de travailler un
peu de son côté a suscité une vibration
des fibres patrimoniales
intérieur qui ont fait que voilà que ça
a été très accompagné une fédération
très heureuse de l'ensemble des
praticien qui parfois travaillaient un
petit peu dans en silo comme on dit
aujourd'hui et puis au bout du compte
une fierté retrouvée par la population
et ça c'est l'élément sur lequel je me
permets d'insister le plus c'est que
c'est un élément social c'est un un
élément qui rassemble qui réunit et qui
est qui a été très fortement apprécié
par la population l'effet sur le
territoire bien sûr il y a un effet
médiatique un projecteur la presse dans
les mois qui suivre on parle dans le
monde entier et donc ça alimente bien
sûr cette fierté mais
aussi ça ça fait parler du territoire et
et donc accompagnant cela une dynamique
sociale alors l'effet sur l'économie
locale c'est un sujet un peu délicat j
reviendrai dans de moment dans un moment
à l'Unesco mais malgré tout cette image
qualitative à un moment où dans la
mondialisation cette activité séculaire
chez nous était menacé d'assombrissement
de couverture
d'uniformisation euh a
suscité et bien le retour par exemple de
grandes marques qui sont venu
s'installer sur le territoire Grassois
je pense à à Christian Dior je pense à
LVMH je pense à lancô à Vitton voilà il
sont venus réinstaller des antennes voir
des laboratoires donc c'est un effet qui
à mon avis a suscité ces grandes marque
par l'image retrouvée d'une économie
historique et ancienne et retrouver une
forme de marketing pour leur pour leur
compte bien entendu un des un
développement du flux touristique assez
notoire même si l'on devine que la
promotion d'un patrimoine immatériel est
plus complexe mais cette
projection de lumière sur le territoire
à la suite de la reconnaissance par
l'UNESCO a bien entendu attiré
l'attention et on constate quel suivi
après parce que la reconnaissance euh
par l'UNESCO évidemment c'est une bombe
de joie et et après voilà quel est le
quel quel qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
après donc nous nous avons évidemment
annoncé que ce n'était pas une fin en
soi que c'était au fond un début et que
notre rôle promis dans notre cahier des
charges dans notre dans notre dans nos
cause cause de sauvegarde c'est de
c'était de péréniser de faire connaî de
partager d'amplifier si c'était possible
cette image de marque et ce savoir-faire
avec la population nous avons mis en
place un comité de suivi avec six pôles
un pôle animation médiation un pôle
soutien à la filière agricole un pôle
développement du fond
documentaire un pôle attractivité du
territoire transmission des savoir bien
sûr puisque c'est aussi un des objets et
communication et nous avons mis
également en place une commission d'Oc 3
parce que nous avons pour ne pas
utiliser l'emblème de l'UNESCO qui est
évidemment extrêmement prudente enfin
rigide mis en place une forme de euh
d'emblème local euh qui fédère
l'ensemble de ces de ces sujets et
effectivement euh dans dans quelques
jours nous allons célébrer le 5e
anniversaire comme l'a dit Pierre sanner
tout à l'heure
pendant une semaine de festivité o on va
rassembler évidemment toutes les
communautés dans la joie et dans la
communication de d'anciens films
d'anciennes conférences d'anciennes
images et cetera et ça va être très très
beau ma stratégie en tant que président
de la de l'association qui a compté
jusqu'à 400 membres au départ de soutien
comme ça avec compement des m et cetera
mon but est a été et il est est en train
de se mettre en place place c'est de
transférer tous les leviers de cette
affaire à la collectivité locale
c'est-à-dire pour assurer la pérénite on
sait bien que les associations mon cher
Pierre ne durent avec efficacité que
quand il y a des
animateurs volontaire mais tout ça n'est
pas forcément toujours durable et nous
avons pensé que petit à petit il fallait
transférer tous ces éléments du pôle des
pôles de du comité de suivi à
l'administration sous l'autorité du
maire du président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération en partenariat avec
l'association Patrimoine Vivant et donc
nous sommes là dans une tripartite j'ai
proposé au maire d'être co-président de
l'association à son adjoint au
patrimoine d'être le président délégué
et petit à petit non pas que je me
retire parce que un homme politique ne
se retire jamais mais en tout cas pas
totalement mais mais voilà c'est une
volonté de transférer et d'assurer la
pérenité du suivi des opérations
quelques petit sentiment et puis je m'en
arrête et recommandation peut-être
compte tenu de la difficulté désormais
de déposer une candidature c'est de plus
en plus difficile à l'Unesco il me ça a
été dit d'ailleurs par je crois par
Thomas oui ou Lili il me semble qu'il
faudra mieux labéliser critériser et
valoriser les éléments du patrimoine
immatériel inscrit à l'Inventaire
national parce que il y a pour l'UNESCO
il y a beaucoup d'appelés PE élu et
aujourd'hui l'inventaire national est
une une liste mais qui ne valorise pas
tellement le territoire qui l'a ou le
territoire ou la communauté qui l' je
pense que il faudrait aussi le
labellliser pas tous mais en tout cas
faire un examen pour pour en écritter
les meilleurs à l'Unesco alors il y a
aussi cette ambigué
euh UNESCO comment gérer les effets
incontournables économiques alors que
UNESCO me tient qu'à la valeur culturel
donc c'est toujours difficile comment
peut-on par évidemment nous nous
interdisons à toutes les marques de
marquer les choses sur leurs étiquettes
c'est évident mais voilà c'est parfois
une frontière un peu délicate
l'association France PCI que je salue
avec le président Pierre Sner ble
l'ensemble des éléments on y constate
une extrême diversité des éléments et on
tâche d'y instaurer et ça c'est c'est
vraiment à mon avis un élément aussi
important des passerelles entre les
différents éléments qui sont inscrit sur
la liste représentative en fonction de
leur éventuelle complémentarité nous
travaillons actuellement avec l'élément
de la construction des murs en pierre
sèches qui ont été reconnus au
patrimoine culturel sur la liste
représentative dans la à la même année
que que nous et il y a évidemment une
complémentarité entre les exploitations
floral du sud de la France et les
restanques et ces malheureuses
malheureux murs en pierre sèche qui ont
malheureusement été démolis ou se sont
démolis tout seul avec le temps
euh voilà et ben j'en ai terminé en tout
cas je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté
j'espère ne pas avoir été trop long
merci cher pire alors vous êtes
plusieurs à vouloir intervenir je vais
vous donner successivement la parole et
puis je vous invite à à
prendre nos nos intervenants prendre
note et des éventuelles questions comme
ça vous pourrez y répondre chacun si
vous le souhaitez on va commencer par
Sonia de la
provoté merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci à tous pour vos
intervention déjà extrêmement complète
et qui bon qui répondent à une partie
des questions et puis à titre voilà
personnel plaisir de de revoir
Jean-Pierre qui évidemment a répondu à
tellement de questions dans son
intervention ENF connaisseur du Sénat et
de nos attentes à nous coupe un peu
l'herbe sous le pied ou les fleurs de
grâce si on peut dire les choses ainsi
néanmoins je je pense que sur ce sujet
qui qui est un sujet
important alors pas
forcément pris dans toute sa mesure au
plan national il me semble je parle du
grand public qui mesure pas forcément
euh les questions de patrimoine
immatériel sauf à traiter de la question
du champ du coq le matin dans les
territoires ruraux comme on a eu à le
faire au travers du euh d'une PPL et on
voit bien que cette question du
patrimoine immatériel
euh on sait euh à à peu près où elle
termine avec ce label mais on ne sait
guerre où elle commence et finalement
c'est notre patrimoine commun et dedans
il y a quelques phares comme ça qui sont
labelllisés euh mais en réalité c'est un
vrai sujet euh qui concerne le vivre
ensemble et qui
concerne notre histoire commune et ce
qu'on se transmet de génération en
génération euh moi j'ai j'ai deux
questions alors on a bien compris qu'il
y a une vie avant le label et puis une
vie après le label euh donc en ce qui
concerne le la vie après la vie avant
avant le label et puis en ce qui
concerne l'UNESCO je me pose vraiment la
question de la dimension de la
territorialisation c'est-à-dire de de
l'impact territorial euh au-delà de la
de la structure associative dont don
dont a parlé Jean-Pierre Leleu on on a
un vrai sujet de euh de lien avec les
collectivités territoriales mais de de
de façon large sur sur le patrimoine et
on a vrai sujet aussi de répartition à
l'échelle du pays c'est-à-dire qu'on
voit bien que peut-être cette dimension
là n'est pas toujours euh aussi
prégnante dans les choix qui sont faits
alors doit-elle l'être peut-être pas
peut-être que la question la
territorialisation d'équité des
territoires n'est pas une question en
matière de de patrimoine immatériel il
n'empêche que la réalité fait que que
dans les choix de label on voit bien
qu'il y a des concentrations et qu'il y
a des territoires qui sont moins moins à
l'affu ou moins en éveil ou peut-être
moins conseillé euh ou soutenu de la
part notamment de des
draces et donc je pense que c'est un
vrai sujet qui qu'il faut regarder cette
cartographie mon deuxème sujet porte sur
dans dans cette dimension justement de
de de faire vivre sur la question de
l'Europe quels sont les liens européen
est-ce que le patrimoine immatériel au
niveau européen c'est une vraie présence
c'est un vrai sujet notre histoire
commune au niveau européen fait qu'on a
des éléments de patrimoine qu'on
retrouve d'un pays à l'autre et ce ce
sujet-là me semble-t-il est un gage de
mieux préserver les savoir-fa et les
différences de savoir-faire sur des
thématiques communes et est-ce que ce
travail est vraiment réellement engagé
euh et et valorisé et puis ma ma ma
dernière question porte sur la stratégie
euh qui pourrait développé euh quand
c'est nécessaire sur la formation pour
maintenir ces fameux savoir-faire dont
on sait qu'une partie de la fragilité
est à la disparition des compétences et
des expertises et donc est-ce qu'il y a
vraiment là je m'adresse peut-être plus
au ministère
mais bien sûr à chacun des des
interlocuteurs est-ce qu'il y a une
vraie
stratégie autour de de de de de ces
métiers et de formation adosser sur sur
ce label du patrimoine de l'Unesco je
vous remercie merci Sabine Drexler qui
est rapporteur budgétaire des crédits
patrimoine pour notre merci merci
monsieur le Président merci pour vos
intervention à tous alors la convention
qui définit le PCI est une définition
large qui a beaucoup d'avantages
notamment celle de ne pas figer des
savoirs et des savoir-faire mais de
permettre leur évolution tout en
reconnaissance des pratiques à la fois
traditionnelles et innovantes alors j'ai
beaucoup travaillé effectivement sur le
patrimoine bâti le petit patrimoine non
protégé qui fait l'identité de nos
régions et aussi rencontrer de nombreux
propriétaire de patrimoine classé ou
inscrits et les monuments nationaux et
tous sont confrontés aux mêmes
problématiques du manque d'artisans et
des artisans d'art pour rénover
restaurer ses biens qui sont si précieux
et en cela le PCI est un outil important
qui concerne aussi ces métiers et
pourrait être un levier de mise en
valeur de ces filières qui peinent à
recruté et qui risquent aujourd'hui de
perdre leur savoir-faire alors tout
comme vous je regrette que le PCI soit
encore trop peu connu et trop peu
valorisé auprès du grand public et des
jeunes dans leur recherche de formation
et j'aurais aimé savoir quels sont les
efforts pour vous de promotion des
métiers d'art et de restauration du
patrimoine qui devrait pouvoir être mis
en place pour inciter les jeunes à se
tourner vers ces filières d'excellence
et donc à en assurer la transmission
merci merci Jean ingret
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues tout d'abord remercier les
intervenants de ce matin pour leurs
propos enthousiassement plus
particulièrement notre collègue l leu
qui a mené le combat pour le le parfum
de grassce et il m'en vient une question
sur chers collègues vous avez montré les
différentes étapes de l'élaboration des
10 ans qui ont conduit à l'obtention du
du label UNESCO mais existe-t-il un
guide pratique pour ces dossiers un
guide pratique pour les collectivités
territoriales qui souhaitent porter un
projet car le guide à destination des
détenteurs des savoir-faire est souvent
compliqué à appréhender notamment en
terme d'attendu
scientifique alors que les candidatures
sont souvent liées un territoire la
participation active des collectivités à
l'élaboration du dossier n'est pas
forcément toujours présent comment mieux
les associer à l'avenir j'avais aussi
une question euh qui rejoint euh celle
de de notre collègue Sonia de la provoté
concernant certains territoires qui
participent entre guillemets plus à la
chasse au au au JP au IGP pardon au
classement aussi à l'Unesco alors que
certains territoires sont ell sont
totalement dépourvu de Labelle j'aurais
aussi une question pour Madame martinet
et Monsieur mousard quel est le volume
des candidatures que vous suivez
annuellement combien se présente mais
combien n'intègre pas pas l'inventaire
et combien l'intègre le nombre de
candidatures qui s'arrêtte semble être
en croissance quelle est votre ambition
pour ces candidatures qui s'arrêtent à
ce stade j'aurais aussi une question
pour
Madame o inata Monsieur Madame martinet
et Monsieur mousard j'aimerais avoir
votre avis sur les quotas et les recours
aux candidatures portées par plusieurs
États notamment plusieurs États
européens et j'ai une dernière question
pour monsieur autorizon vous avez cité
différents masters en patrimoine
culturel immatériel quel en sont les les
débouchés et quels en sont les taux
d'insertion professionnelle voilà je me
permets de poser toutes ces questions
parce que j'ai aussi dans mon territoire
la volonté de porter euh une
labellisation à l'Unesco de la luterie
de mircour et de l'arquétere et donc
voilà j'en fais déjà la promotion il
serapportter naturellement voilà j'en
suis là j'en profite on fêtera tout ça
tous ensemble j'espère dans 5 ou 10 ans
selon l'étendue des des travaux et c'est
un beau projet qu'on porte avec Monsieur
le Maire de mircour et la présidente
ainsi que toutes les les communautés
donc on on défendra avec force et
vigueur ce projet et on espère fêter
tous ensemble l'obtention de ce label je
vous remercie le le compte àambourg des
10 années et et commencé Jean-Jacques
lezac
oui merci monsieur le le président euh
moi il se trouve que j'ai été le le
président fondateur de la Cité
internationale de la tapicerie d'
buusson donc ma question s'adresse plus
particulièrement à Monsieur sanner comme
président de l'association France PCI et
c'est vrai que cette cette réalisation
de la cité a été je dirais la la
conséquence directe la déclinaison très
matérielle très très pratique du
classement au PCI qui remonte à 2009
donc ça a été un des premiers
classements en France mais euh ça n'a
pas été non plus un chemin bien bien
tranquille puisque l'inauguration
c'était 2016 par contre moi je suis
intimement convaincu que en terme de de
financement des investissements s'il n'y
avait pas eu ce classement là on naurait
pas vu la fondation hermè ou la
Fondation B encour intervenir dans ce
type d'investissement et tout à l'heure
quelqu'un disait que ce ce ce classement
était un véritable outil de de
démocratie culturelle c'est évident mais
c'est aussi un formidable outil de
développement économique et de promotion
touristique au Buson c'est 3200
habitants euh donc ma ma question c'est
en particulier sur le suivi qu'est-ce
qui se passe après et je voudrais savoir
si il y a eu par exemple des des
conventionnements des des partenariats
entre des collectivités territoriales et
la maison France PCI parce que je pense
effectivement que c'est très important
de de ne pas laisser ensuite un petit
peu dans dans dans l'isolement dans la
solitude c'est ces territoires qui ont
obtenu le le classement donc voilà ma
ma ma
question merci Alexandra borqu
fontin merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs mes chers
collègues avant d'entrer dans le vif de
mon propos il'est impossible de ne pas
saluer mon ami Jean-Pierre lelon ancien
sénateur des Alpes marities membre de
cette commissionci un maire de grâce
merci en tout cas cher Jean-Pierre pour
ton application ton ta détermination S5
en faveur de notre patrimoine culturel
immat en tout cas il n'est plus à
démontrer je le rappelle donc c'est
grâce à toi que notre territoire
azurrien rayonne puisque l'art de
composer le parfum au pays de Grass et
depuis 2018 reconnu par l'UNESCO comme
un
savoir-faire c'est une reconnaissance
bien sûr de l'ensemble de la population
Mar alpine d'ailleurs ce rayonnement ne
se limite pas à grass puisque plus de
500 hectares de la ville de Nice dont la
Promenade des Anglais le montboron on
rejoint en 2021 ce classement de renommé
mais jamais 203 comme mon collègue Jean
inré je voulais vous alerter sur la
candidature canoise cette fois pour
l'inscription de l'archipel de l'érins
là d'ailleurs où la communauté
monastique est présente depuis le 16e
siècle le ministère de la Culture a
inscrit l'île saintte-honora sur la
liste indicative nationale il a fa fallu
d'ailleurs 6 ans pour obtenir cette
inscription il en faudra
vraisemblablement encore six pour que
l'île soit inscrite au patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO donc même si nous
faisons partie des benjamins du Sénat
avec Jean inré nous espérons fortement
chacun pouvoir célébrer euh cette
reconnaissance au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO je souhaitais donc par ces mots
vous l'avez compris vous rappeler
l'intérêt de suivre ce site et de
classer cette candidature au nom du
patrimoine exceptionnel de notre pays et
comme l'a rappelé d'ailleurs Jean-Pierre
l Leleu au ministère et à l'Unesco mais
chez les élus aussi les hommes et les
femmes se lèvent et se rempl donc merci
de bien vouloir suivre ce
dossier
Adel
zan merci président merci beaucoup pour
votre présence chers collègues je
remercie les rédacteur du rapport pour
la qualité des propositions qui sont
faites mais également les collègues mes
mes anciens collègues du ministère de la
Culture pardon pour évoquer un certain
nombre de points concernant ce sujet je
rejoins ce que vous disiez monsieur Sané
sur nous-même en tant qu'élu de
territoire nous sommes les
promoteurs de patrimoine culturel
matériel corps défendant j'ai envie de
dire il y a une vraie et mauvaise
appréhension et compréhension du sujet
par le grand public bien évidemment et
moi je l'explique on en discutait très
rapidement tout à l'heure par la force
que le classement UNESCO en terme de
patrimoine matériel porte évidemment on
connaît le classement le tagemal la
lambrra divers divers sites qui sont
dans le monde classés et qui sont des
vrais vecteurs d'attractivité pour les
territoires et aujourd'hui on a cette
nécessité de travailler sur ce
patrimoine culturel matériel le rendre
vivant le rendre palpable s'agissant
d'un patrimoine culturel mat matériel
qui lui-même existe et matériel et
physique et on a cette difficulté
aujourd'hui à à à construire et je pense
qu'il y a des pistes dans le rapport j'y
reviendrai qui sont un vrai vecteur de
de de d'avancer de ce point de vue-là je
j'insiste pour ma part on en discutait
merci pour cher Jean-Pierre lu sur la
discussion que nous avons nous avons pu
avoir sur le rôle majeur des
collectivités territoriales des villes
des élus et je pense qu'il faut insister
plus fortement encore sur ce rôle je
viendrai aussi sur des propositions en
sensibilisant les les élus municipaux en
par particulier parce qu'on a vrai on a
vraiment à travers ce patrimoine
culturel immatériel de vrais outils de
cohésion sociale c'est évoqué dans le
rapport mais je me permets d'insister
sur ce point des outils un outil de
transmission
intergénérationnelle d'appropriation
capacité de rendre vivant on en parlait
les territoire de sensibiliser de
redonner une attractivité au territoire
vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le sénateur
lu et c'est l'interaction aussi avec les
atouts et les attraits économiques mais
également l'élargissement de l'offre
culturelle qui dans des territoires qui
parfois fois apparaissre comme des
déserts culturels peut être un vrai
outil de vivification de revivification
moi un point qui reste sur lequel je
reste un tout petit peu sur ma fin euh
mais j'arrive tout récemment c'est sur
on parle de la diversité culturelle
c'est le titre du rapport il y a un mot
qui manque à mon sens un petit peu c'est
la notion de mondialisation on avance
progressivement de plus en plus vers une
société globale mondialisée on en
discute régulièrement avec mon collègue
Yan Chantrel sur les questions de
francophonie une société globale
mondialisée qui va vers une
homogénéisation des goûts une
homogénéisation des pratiques une
homogénéisation de la pratique
architecturale des pratiques culturelles
de la vision du monde et le patrimoine
culturel immatériel joue un rôle
déterminant et doit jouer un rôle
déterminant dans la préservation de ces
spécificités de cette diversité culturel
peut-être qu'on le voit pas assez dans
le rapport je l'ai parcouru je l'ai
regardé et mais de mon point de vue
c'est un sujet qu'on doit porter
monsieur San vous parlez des maisons des
cultures du monde que je connais un
petit peu joue ce rôle justement de
préservation dans un monde de plus en
plus homogénéisé du point de vue des
pratiques culturelles et de la culture
au sens large je parle même pas des
réseaux sociaux de ce point de vue-là et
je regardais avec beaucoup d'intérêt c
la carte qui est situé pas 11 11 du
rapport oui c'est ça sur les éléments
communs à plusieurs états là aussi on
parlait de régionalité de capacité à ne
pas être seulement sur des régions des
départements mais également d'éléments
communs du patrimoine culturel
immatériel de l'humanité qui serait
internationaux à cheval sur des
frontières même pas forc des frontières
communes vous l'évoquiez dans votre
présentation madame et qui permettrait
justement ce travail autour d'une de de
de sensibilisation à une échelle plus
large pour mes propositions je regardis
les questions les recommandations 3 et 4
j'en conclurai là-dessus les
recommandations 3 et 4 qui sont en écho
avec ce que je disais en introduction
avec cette force qui a le patrimoine
culturel matériel dans l'esprit dans
l'imaginaire commun de nos de nos
citoyennes et citoyens peut-être aller
vers une s'appuyer sur les journées
patrimoniales euh du journé du
patrimoine national pour intégrer
insérer un élément plus fort en terme de
patrimoine culturel immatériel la
recommandation aussi numéro 10 qui va
avec ce que Monsieur Sané disait tout à
l'heure mais une interaction plus forte
avec les DRAC et les directions des
affaires culturelles des communes pour
être en capacité justement de s'appuyer
sur des sur des propositions émergent
des territoires et j'en profite aussi
puisque le marché opus de saint-toin
dans sa vision aussi de la préservation
des savoir-faes puissiers Antier
brocanteur chineur et cetera s'apprête à
proposer sa candid ure donc je vous
remercie de de l'étudier avec
bienveillance et on aura l'occasion d'en
discuter à de nombreuses reprise je vous
remercie
merciine
commence merci Monsieur le présent avec
ma collègue Jose nous avons le plaisir
de terminer un
rapport sur l'expertise patrimoniale
française patrimonale et muséal
française à l'étranger aussi on a été
particulièrement intéressé lorsque
madame wiinata a indiqué que la France
était le le pays qui avait reçu le le le
plus qui avait le plus d'éléments
inscrits dans le cadre des des
candidatures transnationales on pourrait
citer la fauconnerie l'alpinisme les
techniques des ateliers des cathédrales
en Europe également on a évoqué tout à
l'heure l'art de la construction de la
la pierre sèche ou encore les les
savoir-faire en mécanique horlogerie ma
question est simple quel est l'intérêt
des inscriptions transnationales en
terme de coopération de long terme et
comment cellees-ci se se
traduisent-elles se matérialise-el avec
quelle retombée aussi quelles
implications pour notre pays et puis
j'ai une deuxième question assez simple
on parle beaucoup de la transmission des
des savoir-faire leur valorisation la
promotion du patrimoine immatériel cuid
des menaces euh qui sont susceptibles de
faire disparaître des P entier justement
de certains artisanad je pense à des
sujets sur lesquels nous nous sommes
battus au Sénat l'année passée l'art du
vitrail et la facture d'or menacé par la
suppression du du plomb hein s'il venait
être inscrit sur la liste des produits
chimiques interdit donc au niveau
européen et je pense ça va faire plaisir
à à Jean parce qu'on s'était mobilisé
là-dessus l'année dernière il défend
l'archéterie la luterie le bois de
pernambou a fait aussi l'objet d'une
menace d'interdiction bois de pernambou
c'est ce qui per permet aussi la
réalisation des archers pour nos
orchestres en particulier bien entendu
mais pas seulement donc comment les uns
et les autres je pense peut-être
davantage au ministère vous mobilisez
sur ces menaces comment peut-on être
efficace aussi pour démontrer voilà
quand même le danger qu'il y aurait à se
voir interdire un certain nombre de de
produit de de base merci de votre
réponse Lord
Arcos
merci président moi aussi je vais aller
de mon ma petite larme en en voyant
notre notre ancien collègue Jean-Pierre
et ravi de te de te recevoir moi ma
question va être très simple parce que
on a déjà eu beaucoup je rebondis sur ce
qu'a dit Sabine tout à l'heure
concernant la les formations
professionnelles pour que ce ce
patrimoine culturel
immatériel survive il faut que nos
jeunes générations soient sensibilisé
moi je le vois pour des petites choses
mais dans des petites églises de
campagne euh j'ai des mares qui prennent
l'initiative de d'y amener leur leurs
écoliers pour qu'ils puissent voir les
Compagnons du Devoir sur place pour les
travails de la pierre du bois et euh
dans tout domaine tout ce que vous avez
pu évoquer euh je voudrais savoir si on
pourrait pas essayer euh non pas de
forcer mais qu'il y ait des formations
professionnelles euh en lien avec euh
les les classements euh dans chaque
territoire pour qu'on puisse peut-être
privilégier d'avoir cette fierté de ces
jeunes qui puissent finalement continuer
à perpétuer ce ce ce patrimoine dans
dans ces territoires définis c'est un
peu plus compliqué pour le le les
cultures alimentaires monsieur sanner
parce qu'il y en a partout mais mon
Marie qui venait de d'ordogne je vous
dire que voilà la culture gourmande de
de pégourdine est très importante et on
a du coup beaucoup d'écoles en en
rapport avec cette ce patrimoine là
merci merci euh nombreuses questions et
points soulevés je ne sais pas comment
vous voulez vous répartir on peut
peut-être prendre les différents thèmes
il les questions autour de la
territorialisation notamment la
cartographie et les la multiplication
enfin le développement des différents
labels et le fait que ça soit parfois
souvent les les mêmes territoires qui
sont les plus actifs dans la recherche
de ces labels je ne sais pas qui veut
intervenir
entre allez-y monsieur
mousard merci bon j'avais dit dans ma
présentation que il s'agissait pas d'un
label et donc je
j'insiste dans le sens où ça n'est pas
une distinction qui serait apporté une
pratique meilleure qu'une autre voilà ça
n'est pas dans l'esprit de la convention
bien au contraire en fait et dans la
mesure où c'est une démarche ascendante
donc des communautés qui vont
effectivement chercher une
reconnaissance soit au niveau de l'État
soit au niveau international avec ave
l'UNESCO mais on parle pas proprement
d'un d'un label
et il faut aussi remarquer que cette
convention ne n'associe pas des
pratiques à à un
territoire il y a pas de voilà de
territoalisation mais bien à une
communauté à entendre comme une
communauté patrimoniale c'estàd
l'ensemble des gens qui font vivre cette
pratique et donc dans dans une certaine
mesure c'est même le contraire il s'agit
de partager une prtique culturelle et
d'inviter tout à chacun à à s'en emparer
à la réinventer et ça aussi c'est un
principe important de la convention que
cette réinvention des pratiques pour
répondre par exemple à à à ma voisine
excusez-moi madame mais j'ai pas retenu
votre votre
nom
merci et vous faisiez allusion à ces à
ces savoir-faire à
l'artisanat qui sont menacés du fait que
les ressources qu'ils utilisent sont
elles-mêmes en en devenu rare et et donc
interdite à juste titre comme le bois du
permou mais faut rappeler par exemple en
l'espèce euh que je crois que le
noisetier peut étit utilisé avant le
permou et donc il y a effectivement
l'impératif écologique à se à se
réinventer à utiliser d'autres
ressources ça s'est déjà vu par le passé
et donc peut-être ne faut-il pas
s'inquiéter plus que ça toujours sur les
euh sur les savoir-faire les artisanat
c'est venu souvent ben je rappelle qu'il
y a une stratégie nationale sur les
métiers d'art bon je renvoie simplement
à cela pour pour dire que c'est une une
des réponses qui a pu être apportter
effectivement on le constate à à la à la
la disparition même dans certains cas
moi je l'ai vu déjà en quelques années
d'activité de de de savoir-faire présent
sur le l artisanat présent sur le
territoire national donc on est tout à
fait conscient que il faut réagir et que
certains se tournent justement vers le
patrimoine culturel im matatériel pour
euh pour bah développer des plans de
sauvegarde parce que c'est ça en fait
plus qu'un label c'est bien ça a été
bien je pense montré dans la
communication l'intervention de de
Jean-Pierre lelleu c'est une invitation
à se mobiliser collectivement à se
responsabiliser collectivement et à
anticiper sur sur des risques hein c'est
je crois que c'est vraiment l'outil que
que qui est proposé à travers
l'inventaire national pour commencer
tant il est vrai en plus que ça a été
souligné les candidatures à l'une UNESCO
sont de plus en plus difficiles à
obtenir et ces quotas ont même introduit
un effet délétaire de compétition entre
eux faut pas le le nier c'est la réalité
et c'est discuté en assemblée
générale à l'Unesco
hein entre ces communautés alors que la
convention défend au contraire la
diversité culturelle le partage le
dialogue constructif entre entre
communautés communauté encore une fois
au sens large euh divers
culturelle oui effectivement c'est un
outil un instrument semble-t-il qui a a
vraiment été créé d'ailleurs après la
déclaration universelle pour la
diversité culturelle de
2001 non seulement à l'échelle mondiale
mais à l'échelle intérieure aussi sur
not sur les territoire et la diversité
culturelle
actuelle donc c'est ce que met en
évidence peut-être plus efficacement
l'inventaire national avec l'inclusion
d'éléments de pratique qu'on pourrait
qualifier de diasporique hein qui sont
sur le territ ire national depuis
quelques dizaines décennies ù notamment
notamment en Île-de-France donc
[Musique]
voilà bon je laisse la parole aux
collègues parce que et aux autres qui
souhaiterai réagir j'ai peut-être trop
parl intervenir pour revenir madame
oinata
oui merci comme mon collègue monsieur Mo
moard pardon on a commencé à répondre
sur les questions d'inscription
peut-être je vais essayer aussi moi de
contribuer à ce point de
discussion monsieur Sénat lu a dit que
la porte de l'UNESCO est assez étroite
en ce qui concerne l'inscription c'est
vrai c'est le nombre 60 qui qui est dans
ma tête 60 dossiers par an que le
secrétariat est demandé à traiter et un
dossier tous les 2 ans au minimum
l'histoire est un peu plus complexe que
cela parce qu' il y a le système de
priorité différentes catégories juste
pour vous montrer un peu de coulisse
notre équipe mais au moins 6 semaines
pour établir à chaque fois après la date
limite de soumission à la fin de mars
pour établir le liste de nom la liste de
candidatures pour pour un un cycle en
question c'est c'est assez complexe
puisqu'il faut éclire aux étates pour
clarifier que les dossier sont en fait
prioritair et cetera et cetera mais si
le PCI n'est pas figé le système
d'inscription n'est pas figé non plus la
convention de 2003 a entamé et complété
la réflexion très globale très
euh complet entre 2018 et
2022 la réflexion globale sur la
mécanisme d'inscription de la Convention
et par le par le VI de cette réflexion
les États parties de la Convention a
confirmé le système d'inscription ils
ont dit oui ils souhaitent continuer le
système basé sur sur les critères
d'inscription ils souhaite confirmer
l'évaluation très rigoureus par l'organ
d'évaluation nous avons proposé une
option pour pour aller dans le sens de
un peu comme liste Wikipédia pour mettre
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'éléments pour pouvoir que à tout le
monde mais en fait la conclusion de tout
le monde l'étapathti était non c'est
mieux d'avoir de continuer de système
avec un peu d'ajustement m de rien nous
avons établi un un processus dit de
dialogue pendant l'évaluation qui permet
deséchanges entre l'organ d'évaluation
de l'état soumissionnaire qui enlève le
tension de
l'inquiétude pour ne pas retarder le
processus inutilement juste parce qu'il
y a des petites question que l'organ ne
peut pas résoudre et cetera et cetera
donc je crois que le
système continue de s'améliorer et aussi
avec la simplification du formulaire on
essaie de inviter les les avis et les
opinions de Communauté en utilisant par
exemple tout simplement le vidéoclip
comme ça ils peuvent mieux s'exprimer et
cetera euh l'opinion sur sur la pratique
sur les éléments qui le Pr
en répondant la question sur les
candidatures multinationaux parce que
c'est vraiment quelque chose que la
France m en
accent la question était c'est quoi
l'entrée l'entrée c'est tout simplement
c'est la meilleure coopération entre les
pays impliqués et je crois que les
représentants de minist ministère est
mieux placé que moi pour parler des
expériences concrètes mais c'est la
coopération international vrai puisque
le processus demande non seulement des
signatures entre des des des pays mais
vraiment le travail au niveau
communautaire au niveau l'association au
niveau des des pays pour monter les
actions
conjointe si je pousse les exemples au
plus plus dramatique j'ai travaillé
personnellement sur le sur la
candidature conjointe entre la
République populaire démocratique de
Corée et la République de Corée qui ont
réussi à mettre les deux éléments
ensemble en 2018 l'année où la l'élément
de de de la grâce a été inscrit c'était
c'était le moment très très fort pour la
convention vous imaginez donc c'est
c'est simplement pour dire que c'est un
mécanisme très important je vous
remercie pour tous les commentaires et
les questions merci madame qui d'autre
veut intervenir
sur les questions de formation
aussi je me
lance ben je vous remercie pour pour
votre question en effet en matière de
formation on est souvent sollicité de la
part enfin par par les universités pour
venir faire des interventions et en
effet présenter un peu le PCI cadre
enjeu méthode intérêt et
cetera on sent un engouement de plus en
plus croissant de la part des
universités par ailleurs autour de ces
question du patrimoine culturel
immatériel ce soit l'Institut national
du patrimoine Sciences Po par exemple ou
même aujourd'hui un master qui été monté
à Toulouse donc ça veut dire que en
effet la société civile les
collectivités les universités se
saisissent aussi de cette question forme
des étudiants qui eux-mêmes irigueront
plus tard finalement ces questions
autour du patrimoine immatériel donc on
sent bien que c'est quelque chose qui
présente de plus en plus d'intérêt alors
quels sont les débouchés à ce jour il
est difficile de d'en trouver mais ont
mise sur l'avenir hein c'est un petit
peu le principe de la formation en
général c'est-à-dire que c'est formé
aussi des des des acteurs pour pour
l'avenir et vraisemblablement ce
patrimoine vivant aura de plus en plus
de place euh je j'en profite pour vous
faire part aussi que la Maison des
Cultures du Monde en tant que ethnopole
met en place également des cycles de
formation à destination des élus locaux
des collectivités territoriales des
agents aussi pour les sensibiliser ces
questions du patrimoine culturel
immatériel il y a deux cycles de
formation un de 12h et un autre de 21h
donc vous pouvez très bien faire appel à
nos services justement pour dispenser ce
type de formation au sein des
collectivités territoriales et enfin
j'ai envie de dire que nous avons dans
le cadre de cette convention donc 2003
les 20 ans de la convention nous avons
mis en place initié au sein de la Maison
des culture du monde en partenariat avec
la convention enfin avec l'Université
Paris lumière et l'Université de nanère
une étude donc qui démarre en septembre
2023 qui courra jusqu'en août 2024 et
qui répondra à bon nombre des questions
on l' esppère qui se sont posé ce matin
je vais vous donner les quatre les cinq
euh thématiques qui seront abordées dans
le cadre de cette enquête donc travail
d'inscription UNESCO donc l'analyse du
processus ensuite vie de la communauté
qu'est-ce qu'il en est alors dans les
communautés patrimoniales on entend
souvent les communautés de lieu les
communautés d'intérêts ou les
communautés de pratique transmission de
la pratique ça a été bien souligné par
ailleurs par de nombreux sénateur et
sénatrices ce matin c'est c'est un enjeu
essentiel justement cette question de la
transmission dans le patrimoine vivant
et enfin la vie après l'inscription
UNESCO comme l'a souligné Monsieur L leu
question très importante et enfin
écriture numérique du PCI euh donc tout
ce qui est valorisation à travers le web
les réseaux sociaux mais pas seulement
c'est aussi des réseaux parfois utilisé
plus sécurisé qu'on ne connaît pas
forcément comme discord ou telgram où il
y a des boucles aussi de gens qui
peuvent discuter à propos du patrimoine
vivant et peut-être d'une manière un peu
moins publique donc c'est aussi une
manière de faire vivre les communautés
du PCI sous sousr d'autres aspects et
donc cette étude là
sera consacrée au 26 éléments inscrits
français sur les listes UNESCO
voilà pour les représentants du
ministère de la Culture il y avait des
demandes de chiffr sur combien de de
demandes et et le lien avec les Dracs
aussi est-ce que au sein des Dracs il y
a des interlocuteurs identifi pour
accompagner les collectivités sur le
monsieur le Président est- que je peux
le ajouter une question vous avez parlé
de for formtion qui est à disposition et
une des recommandations qui a été cité
d'ailleurs la dit c'était d'un V mettre
en place un Vcom merci est-ce que
c'est donc sur la question par rapport
au volume de demande et donc pour
l'inventaire national en moyenne on a
environ entre 15 et 20 éléments inclus
par an ce qui est ce qui est important
en en nombre mais on n pas parce que
certaines fiches vont revenir plusieurs
fois c'est-à-dire elles vont passer
devant le comité du patrimoine
etnologique et matériel qui est l'organe
consultatif pour la mise en œuvre de la
Convention en France au sein de la
Direction générale des patrimoines et de
l'architecture et donc certaines fiches
vont vont
mettre plusieurs passages parce qu'il y
a les experts qui vont se prononcer donc
il va falloir retravailler la fiche
donc dans dans ces 15 euh parfois c'est
ça a déjà été présenté une année
précédente ou au niveau des refus nous
notre objectif et notre rôle avec avec
Thomas mousard
c'est d'accompagner les porteurs donc
notre objectif c'est que les fiches
soient incluses à l'Inventaire national
parfois ça ne réussit pas donc les les
refus sont quand même très marginaux je
dirais
environ quatre par an c'est c'est
maximum c'est notre objectif est
finalement si on voit qu'il n'y a aucune
chance qu'une demande prospère de
l'arrêter dès le début pour éviter un
investissement en temps et en moyen des
porteurs ensuite il y a des personnes
qui se découragent et c'est c'est vrai
que la que ce soit pour les procédures
au niveau national ou international il y
a un certain degré de technicité euh
d'expertise et de connaissance qui n'est
pas la porter de toutes les communautés
et et ça c'est une réalité donc nous
quand on peut quand on a les moyens on
fait une mise en relations avec des
chercheurs on essaie de soutenir mais on
n'est pas on n pas les moyens suffisants
pour le faire pour chaque
communauté h
ensuite sur la question des dragues donc
Thomas on a parlé on a des référents
patrimoine culturel matériel en DRAC on
on a des difficultés euh qui sont avec
des changements de poste donc parfois on
a un référent et puis il part il n'est
pas remplacé donc on a certaines zones
où on a encore besoin
de d'identifier des référents patrimoine
culturel matériel souvent c'est des
personnes qui vont cumuler des
responsabilité donc ils sont déjà
référents musées donc ça ça pose aussi
des questions on a eu cette année une
première formation euh patrimoine cultur
matéel euh au niveau de
du ministère de la Culture et on a eu
plusieurs référent Dr qui sont venus se
se former donc ça c'était très positif
parce que ils ont il y a une certaine
appréhension comme le patrimoine vivant
n'est pas suffisamment connu
euh les les personnes en drag se sentent
pas prêtes à prendre des dossiers donc
c'est c'est aussi euh à nous de réussir
euh à les former et à les accompagner
c'est c'est un travail de de
longuealinee
euh et euh je vais très rapidement
parler des candidats nature
multinationale donc pour nous c'est
quelque chose qui est très très
intéressant parce que comme le
patrimoine culturel matérial est lié à
des communauté qui qui parfois dépassent
les
territoires des états on voit naître des
relations et ça crée vraiment des des
synergies des échanges de bonnes
pratiques je pense notamment à la pierre
sèche où on a tout un réseau européens
au niveau de la pierre sèche ce qui est
vraiment intéressant parce qui mettre en
place des projets européens pour revenir
à la question sur l'Union européenne on
voit que l'Union européenne est vraiment
euh sollicité par les porteurs pour
mettre en place des projets
transnationaux européens donc ça peut
être des financements FEDER Interreg et
parfois ces financements vont être à
l'origine de candidature je pense
notamment au à une candidature en cours
en lien avec le patrimoine alimentaire
alpin qui est né d'un projet de
recherche financé par l'Union européenne
donc qui maintenant est en train de se
transformer en une reconnaissance
patrimoniale donc je pense ça assez
intéressant et je voulais juste profiter
d'avoir la parole pour pour évoquer deux
choses les droits culturels on en a pas
parlé mais la mise en œuvre de la
Convention et la convention c'est
vraiment ancré dans la matrice des
droits culturels euh tout ce qui est
sauvegarde du patrimoine culturel
matériel contribu à la réalisation des
droits culturels je sais que je crois
que c'est une des responsabilités
d'ailleurs des collectivités
territoriales de de mettre en œuvre ces
droits culturels donc à travers le
patrimoine vivant on met en œuvre les
droits culturels et également quelque
chose qui m'inquiète c'est dans dans les
questions qui ont été posées on parle
beaucoup de transmission formelle de
formation mais il faut pas oublier que
le patrimoine vivant passe aussi
par une formation qui une transmission
informelle qui peut être au sein de la
famille d'autres unités et que le
patrimoine culturel matériel va bien
au-delà des savoir-faire il y a aussi
tous les événements festifs les
expressions orales les arts du spectacle
les connaissances liées à la nature et à
l'univers donc les problématiques des
savoir-faire elles sont très importantes
mais tous les autres domaines du
patrimoine culturel matériel ont des
problématique autes par exemple pour les
événements festifs on a des enjeux très
importants liés à la Sécur à la sécurité
euh les problèmes le covid ça a été des
grandes difficultés il y a certaines
fêtes qui avaient lieu depuis
euh depuis des centtaines et centtaines
d'années qui n'ont pas eu lieu euh les
questions liées au à la sécurité en
raison des attentats c'est aussi un
autre enjeu et et et c'est là la la
grande complexité de la mise en œuvre de
la convention c'est que on a cette
grande diversité de d'éléments avec des
besoins très différents donc on n' pas
on n pas quelque chose qui peut
être un modèle qui s'applique à tout on
doit à chaque fois
adapter Monsieur S et puis Jean-Pierre l
leuf pour
conclure merci monsieur le Président euh
juste à propos du du une de questions
autour du suivi euh ce qui me permet
aussi d'ailleurs de je crois c'était à
on était on était à au Buisson n'est-ce
pas et elle a elle a a cité la
tapisserie de buon de préciser que le
vice-président de l'association France
pessie est également le directeur de la
cité de la tapisserie de d' buusson et
Gérard qui œuvre beaucoup euh pour une
pour une meilleure connaissance du euh
du patrimoine culturel immatériel et je
pense que certains d'entre vous ont pu
voir les les les œuvres récentes de
tapisserie qui participent de cette
recréation permanente autour de de
l'œuvre de de Miyasaki ou de toulkien et
dont ça a été présenté sur toute la
région tout le territoire de la la
nouvellequitaine donc le le pour ce qui
est du suivi il y a il y a deux ordres
enfin de deux niveaux probablement l'un
qui est formel et d'ailleurs ça me
surprend que la question n pas été posée
est-ce que l'inscription est reconnue et
et la reconnaissance UNESCO est aDVITAM
ou est-elle sous le jou de sanctions
éventuelles euh fort heureusement à ce
jour je crois pas que de d'élément a pu
être retiré de d'une liste mais on se
doit et et France pi avec les services
de de de de l'État à deux pardon ou
après
euh
euh accompagne le le la la rédaction des
rapports euh qu'il s'agit de de rendre
régulièrement par les par les services
de l'État ce rapport c'est tous les 6
ans je parle sous couvert de voilà donc
il y a quand même ce ce travail de suivi
euh extrêmement important euh après les
les là je prends l'autre casquette la
casquette mission française du
patrimoine et culture alimentaire euh
l'essentiel d'une d'une candidature et
qu'elle soit au niveau de l'nationale ou
après une quête d'un d'une
reconnaissance internationale avec euh
une candidature à à l'Unesco et
également travailler sur les mesures
dites de sauvegarde donc c'est
effectivement le le la question de la
viabilité de l'élément et donc de mettre
en place des politiques publiqu qui
favorise une meilleure connaissance de
l'élément concerné pour ce qui était du
repa gastique des Français vous le savez
on est en train de créer ce réseau des
cités de la gastronomie qui sont des
espaces de formation de promotion de
valorisation et qui participent de
l'attractivité des territoires de la
même manière que pour la la la cité de
la tapisserie à à auusson donc je pense
que la la et d'ailleurs favoriser le
tourisme à la faveur d'une d'une
reconnaissance euh au sein de l'UNESCO
n'est pas non plus un gros mot et c'est
la raison pour laquelle on peut perdre
pleinement s'en s'en emparer et faire
développer des des du tourisme que je
qualifierais de de d'intelligent donc
oui ça participe la de la valorisation
des territoires un point de précision
sur les communautés les communautés ne
sont pas exclusivement des petites
communauté preuve en est qu'un certain
nombre d'éléments dont le repas gque des
Français a été inscrit au titre de la
communauté nationale donc on peut
envisager des candidatures de cette de
cet ordre euh également avec des
répercussions sur l'ensemble des
territoires pour ce qui est des des des
cultures alimentaires comme l'a dit la
satrice d' d'Arcos
euh le le point sur la rapidement parce
que ça je pense qu'il faut effectivement
il y a les formations il y a la il y a
la transmission il y a les praticiens
euh mais peut-être qu'il serait utile
recommandation numéro 10 de de de votre
rapport euh madame Monier c'est le le
euh la la boîte à outil le Val des Mcom
et et je me souviens je se trouve qu'il
était là dans le dans les dans les
papiers euh on s'est inspiré c'est bien
de regarder ce qui se passe aussi
parfois ailleurs euh d'une d'une boîte à
outil réalisée par la Ville de Québec
par le par par Québec disant voilà le
patrimoine immatériel pour la vitalité
de la culturel local et il y avait tous
les éléments en direction des
représentants des des collectivités
territoriales de différents niveaux pour
s'emparer de ce processus et engager une
démarche en direction de l'ventard
national ou et puis après en direction
de d'une éventuelle candidature mais le
plus important c'est effectivement et
c'était le cas je pense pour l'ensemble
des des des candidats c'est pas tant le
le de mettre la l'inscription au revers
de sa veste mais véritablement de mettre
en place des politiques publiques de
transmission par la suite donc les
mesures savegarde sont aussi au cœur de
cette démarche de de du Patrimoine
Vivant voilà merci Jean-Pierre
Leleu merci monsieur le Président
quelques mots rapides pour réagir à
quelques questions qui ont été posés
dans dans le débat le premier point
concerne un élément important qui est la
la formation et la transmission nous
dans notre exemple pendant des siècles a
été cette transmission familiale elle a
été et elle continue il y a des
généalogies qui se sont constituées au
fil des années des décennies voire des
sièclles on transmet dans les familles
et l'enfant succède aux parents les
enfants succèdent aux parents on on
transmet dans les ateliers euh où on
commence comme apprenti on devient un
expert et on transmet également dans les
familles pour la pour la création des
parfums ceci étant cela n'empêche pas
que les institution plus officielles se
lance dans des structures de formation
et notre démarche UNESCO a accompagner
un certain nombre d'outils dans tous les
segments de la filière je pense à
l'École Supérieure du parfum qui est
venu
s'installer sur le territoire dans notre
démarche je pense également et presque
surtout
l'aromatique FabLab qui a été créée par
une association qui s'appelle fleur
d'exception et qui forme les
agriculteurs spécifiquement pour les
plantes d' parfum et je sait si c'est ce
sont des techniques délicates et qui
maintenant fabrique des des petits plans
pour permettre justement de développer
euh cette cette culture je dirais que la
municipalité dans le cadre des mesures
de sauvegarde a ouvert 70 hectares
de sol au zone agricole pour permettre
justement à des exploitants de venir
s'installer après la formation et la
transmission le guide pratique
alors c'est difficile de mettre un guide
pratique en place contteenu de la
diversité des démarches en réalité en
fonction de l'élément concerné le
premier point je dirais ça sera le
respect des critères parce qu'il y a des
critères dans le cahier des charges
aussi bien du ministère de la Culture
que de l'UNESCO il y a des des critères
à respecter premier point deuxème pour
élaborer son guide pratique individuelle
personnellement tout en prenant en
compte les causes générales et au fond
d'aller regarder quand même le site de
l'UNESCO et de regarder l'ensemble des
dossiers d'inscription ça donnera quand
même une idée parce qu'ils sont très
divers mais ça donnera une idée au
demandeurs euh de d'organiser euh son
son guide pratique euh le meilleur
conseil c'est de consulter le ministère
de la Culture voilà c'est le premier
rendez-vous qu'il faut prendre euh de
manière à voir si c'est une idée folle
si c'est une idée qui euh n'est pas
folle mais qui mérite d'être
reconstruite et donc c'est très
important d'avoir cet accompagnement du
ministère de la Culture euh et de de
voilà ensuite le dernier point et
j'insiste un peu parce que c'est quelque
chose qui à mon avis est rencontré comme
difficulté par pas mal d'éléments déjà
inscrits et ça a été évoqué ce sont des
menaces qui pèsent sur sur beaucoup
d'éléments inscrits au patrimoine
culturel immatériel c'est l' c'est la
multiplication des normes et des règles
qu'ell soi
national gouvernemental préfectorale
ou qu'elle soit internationale
européenne notamment qui
bride l'émergence de ces histoires
anciennes
euh si vous le permettez j'ai évoqué ce
sujet avec nos amis de l'alpinisme qui
ont été reconnus il y a pas longtemps et
qui évidemment reconnaissent qu'il y a
des risques à aller au sommet et qu'il
est évidemment légitime pour les
pouvoirs publics de dire c'est interdit
la nuit on peut pas mettre une tente de
faire un un arrêt comment ça s'appelle
enfin
une
hein un bivoac euh voilà et c'est de
plus en plus interdit et donc euh la
difficulté de promouvoir euh devient
complexe prend mon exemple personnel le
parfum il est largement menacé par des
directives européennes qui interdisent
ou
contingente un certain nombre de
substances au profit
d'ailleurs de démarches plutôt nthth
européennes qui elles n'ont pas de
matière premièrees naturell pas de
fleurs et qui préconisent de du
synthétique et et et donc ça devient
extrêmement difficile prend l'exemple
des lavandes actuellement les lavandes
sont menacées par des restrictions sous
prétexte effectivement que l'on peut
comprendre du caractère allergène de
certaines essences mais c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que je ne
suis pas certain que les experts de la
Commission européenne soit les mieux
placés pour distinguer ce qui revient du
produit naturel d'un produit dangereux
et d'un non dangereux et c'est pas me
semble-t-il sous prétexte que un un
consommateur sur 10000 fait une crise de
de durticire en mangeant des fraises
qu'il faut interdire les fraises on en
est là actuellement avec la Commission
européenne voilà je voulais et le
vitrail qui a été cité par par Madame
main de sa est un élément aussi et ces
menaces sont multiples car elles vont
ell elles il y a une rencontre entre la
volonté de l'UNESCO de promouvoir la
diversité et justement la convention de
2003 a été créée pour justement que ces
savoir-fa subsistent dans un contexte
d'uniformisation de la du monde alors
même que parallèlement de plus en plus
de règles
sont et dictées pour à l'encontre de ces
préservations donc c'est un paradoxe que
l'on peut comprendre hein je ne le
critique pas on peut le comprendre mais
il mérite quand même
vigilance voilà j'ai tout dit merci
Jean-Pierre le mot de la fin la fait
juste Jean-Pierre tu sais que sur le
règlement huile essentielle Europe
européen voilà il y a quand même une
petite éclairci et une exception faite
avec le règlement CLP qui a étéé pour 6
ans mais il faut être très vigilant moi
je suis très heureuse de cette de ce
débat que nous avons eu de cette table
ronde je crois que le Sénat montre
comment il s'est travaillé puisque nous
avons été précurseurs quand nous avons
fait ce rapport je crois que c'est
Catherine Mourine de saill qui l'avait
proposé on est venu me chercher j'étais
vraiment comme Monsieur Jourdain en fait
je pratiquer mais je ne savais pas ce
que c'est et Madame Martinet vous vous
avez parlé de des des Fest des éléments
festifs moi c'était la fête des bouviers
à laquelle je participa j'à Gané en fait
c'est un élément vous avez bien expliqué
en quoi c'était compliqué combien le
territoire les élus apporter cela moi je
dis souvent le patrimoine vivant c'est
notre ADN de nos territoires et c'est et
c'est important alors on se rend compte
et ça j'en suis très heureuse que vous
vous êtes toutes celles et ceux qui sont
au cœur de de de ce patrimoine culturel
et matériel saisi de ce rapport et des
recommandation ça fait vraiment plaisir
mais on comprend aussi qu'il y a encore
une marche qui est haute à à franchir et
je crois que nous en tant que
parlementaire on a notre rôle aussi pour
continuer à le rendre visible et à ce
que vous ayez les moyens entre autres de
continuer vos missions et puis puisque
tout le monde a parlé de un peu chez soi
alors moi ce sont les paysages culturels
de la Vand on sait pas si c'était
hfactif au départ donc si c'était
olfactif c'était plutôt PCI si c'est
paysage culturel ça sera peut-être plus
matériel mais donc je suis aussi au cœur
d'un d'un dossier et c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est passionnant et
vous vous rendez compte que ça nous
touche toutes et tous voilà merci merci
à nos intervenants de de vos éclairages
et et de vos intérêt partagé vous avez
compris que nous y sommes très attentifs
au niveau de la Commission sur cette
question du du patrimoine vivant et on
ne manquera pas de faire de travailler
de nouveau avec vous pour prolonger
cette dynamique initiée par
la par l'UNESCO en 2003 merci beaucoup
est-ce qu'on alors je